je ne sais pas
bon très bien
mes chers collègues je vous propose
qu'on commence cette table ronde
et je pense que nos collègues vont nous
rejoindre
mes chers collègues nous avons le grand
plaisir d'accueillir aujourd'hui 5
intervenants majeurs de la filière
française du nucléaire et de sa
régulation monsieur le Président
Directeur Général du Groupe EDF monsieur
Luc Rémond que nous avons vu il n'y a
pas très très longtemps donc nous
accueillons désormais dans ces fonctions
avec plaisir monsieur le Président de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire la SN
Monsieur Bernard de rotsu voilà merci
Monsieur d'être ici Monsieur
l'administrateur général du Commissariat
général à l'énergie atomique et aux
énergies renouvelables je n'oublie pas
Monsieur Christian Jacques Monsieur le
Directeur exécutif du réseau de
transport d'électricité RT Monsieur
Thomas véranc bienvenue à vous et
monsieur le Président Dora nos project à
ma gauche monsieur Guillaume Durot en
tout cas merci beaucoup à vous 5 d'avoir
accepté cette table ronde je crois que
nous n'avons jamais eu dans ce format là
autant de compétences autour de
l'énergie et du nucléaire
en une seule fois
cette table ronde et bien sûr suivie sur
internet en direct je lui dis pour
l'ensemble de nos collègues mais aussi
pour vous 5 notre commission est plus
généralement une majorité assez large au
Sénat se réjouit de la relance de la
filière du nucléaire annoncé j'allais
dire enfin par le Président de la
République dans son discours de Belfort
en février dernier et présenté par le
gouvernement dans le projet de loi
d'accélération des procédures liées à la
construction et au fonctionnement des
réacteurs qui sera examinée par le Sénat
tout début janvier 2023 et qui fait
naturellement l'objet de cette audition
commune notre commission c'est prononcé
souvent mais particulièrement dans un
rapport d'information de juillet dernier
intitulé nucléaire et hydrogène
l'urgence d'agir pour le maintien d'un
mixte majoritairement nucléaire à
l'horizon 2050 ce qui supposerait
d'après ce rapport très bien construit
de construire au moins 14pr contre 6
annoncé actuellement pour réussir cette
relance du nucléaire il faut s'en donner
les moyens politiques il faut s'en
donner les moyens financiers mais aussi
humains naturellement la relance de la
production va de pair avec des exigences
fortes et incontournables s'allier au
cycle du combustibles y compris dans son
expression ultime
ultime s'allier à la sûreté et à la
sécurité c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons toutes ces compétences autour
de cette table ce matin je vous propose
de poser à chacun d'entre vous une
question luminaire puis notre collègue
Daniel Grémillet président du groupe
d'études énergies rapporteur pour notre
commission sur le projet de loi précité
vous interrogera à son tour je salue
bien sûr la présence à cette table ronde
de Pascal Martin rapporteur pour avis
sur ce texte pour la Commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable et probablement
Gérard Longuet qui est vice-président de
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques
nous rejoindra et on connaît tous son
engagement sur ces sujets depuis
longtemps ce sont aussi des voies
expertes et diverses du Sénat qui vous
questionneront sur le projet de loi mais
aussi plus généralement sur le devenir
crucial du nucléaire en France ma
première question ira à monsieur le
Président lucrimont avec les premières
semaines passées à la tête d'EDF
j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous
indiquer si le projet de loi tel qu'il
nous est présenté vous paraît suffisant
pour la relance de la filière nucléaire
en France et pour et
si il prend les décisions nécessaires
pour que ces opérations soient
réalisables dans les meilleures
conditions de temps de lieu de capacité
pour EDF et bien sûr pour la sûreté mais
nous y reviendrons plus tard les
souplesse administratives proposées
sont-elles de nature à accélérer
véritablement les délais de construction
mais ne manquons pas encore de
l'essentiel c'est à dire une stratégie
globale une feuille de route générale et
bien sûr un financement ou en est la
sélection des sites nous parlons de
panier nous parlons de Gravelines bien
sûr qui serait en lice qu'en est-il du
budget qu'en est-il de Tricastin qu'en
est-il presque ce n'est pas de la
provocation mais de Fessenheim
par ailleurs je souhaiterais que
monsieur le président de l'ASN vous
puissiez nous préciser si le projet de
loi semble également suffisamment
intégré bien sûr les enjeux de sûreté et
les enjeux de sécurité les missions de
la SN sont modifiées par les
prolongations ou les arrêts des
réacteurs
pardon l'émission de la SN sont
modifiées pour les prolongations
notamment ou pour les arrêts des
réacteurs est-ce pertinent
quelle garantie avez-vous obtenu en
contrepartie de ces aménagements les
modalités d'associations du public sont
elles aussi ajustées ces évolutions
garantissent-elles tout de même une
participation et une information
suffisante enfin les moyens de
coercition et de sanctions dont dispose
désormais l'ASN récemment dotées d'une
commission des sanctions sont-ils
adaptées à la relance de la filière
monsieur l'administrateur général du CE1
pourriez-vous nous préciser la nature du
rôle d'appui du CEA à la relance du
nucléaire indiquée par le Président de
la République dans son discours de
Belfort comment allez-vous intervenir à
la fois dans le processus de conception
et dans l'exécution et le contrôle bien
sûr de ces projets Monsieur le Directeur
Dorado project quant à vous pouvez ne
vous nous dire ce que vous pensez de la
place accordée au cycle du combustible
dans ce projet de loi de considérez-vous
pas qu'il est en effet le parent pauvre
du projet de loi ce texte se focalise
surtout sur la construction des
réacteurs au rhume le relance du
nucléaire ne doit-elle pas également
prendre en compte l'aval du cycle la
question des combustibles mais aussi
l'Amon celle des déchets si oui comment
auriez-vous souhaité comment
souhaitez-vous que ce sujet soit traité
par ailleurs pourriez-vous nous dire un
mot de la disponibilité en France des
compétences nécessaires à l'étude de ce
cycle c'est l'un des enjeux relevés par
notre commission dans son rapport
d'information sur la souveraineté
économique qui a été publiée en juin
dernier enfin Monsieur le Directeur
exécutif de RTE pourriez-vous nous
indiquer sur le projet de loi vous
paraît susceptible de garantir un mixte
électrique solide dans son étude future
énergétique à l'horizon 2050 RTA relevé
que la durée de construction des
réacteurs est passé de 6-8 mois dans les
années 80 à 12 à 16 ans 6 à 8 ans pardon
pas moi 6 à 8 ans dans sa ça serait
voilà c'est Noël mais enfin quand même 6
à 8 ans dans les années 80 à 12 à 16 ans
actuellement qu'est-ce qui explique cet
allongement est-il propre à la France
pensez-vous que le projet de loi permet
de retrouver cette agilité des années 80
au moins sur les sites existants de plus
certaines soulignaient la nécessité de
décider dès 2022-2023 pour obtenir des
réacteurs en service en
2035-2037 c'est bien sûr crucial pour
éviter l'effet falaise de la fermeture
des réacteurs actuels en fin de vie en
renvoyant toute décision à la prochaine
loi quinquennale sur l'énergie qui ne
sera examinée probablement qu'avant pas
avant la fin de l'année le projet de loi
ne manque-t-il pas en effet sa cible je
vous passe la parole pour répondre à ces
premières questions et puis ensuite nous
aurons nos rapporteurs voilà Monsieur
Raymond je vous laisse monsieur le
Président Directeur Général je vous
laisse la parole merci beaucoup madame
la Présidente bonjour mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et chers
collègues c'est un vrai plaisir pour moi
de revenir devant votre commission
quelques semaines après
mon audition par votre commission et
encore moins de semaine après ma prise
de cette fonction pour parler d'un sujet
qui est absolument essentiel qui est
l'accélération de des procédures
relatives au secteur nucléaire sachant
qu'en parallèle vous travaillez je le
sais également sur l'accélération des
procédures relatives renouvelables et
dans les deux cas ces textes vise à
réduire le temps de développement des
nouveaux moyens de production
d'électricité décarbonée alors vu de DF
naturellement ces deux ambitions sont
plus utiles elles sont nécessaires
et même indispensable
naturellement vous l'avez rappelé madame
la Présidente tout ce qui s'inscrit dans
une politique énergétique qui est
définie par le Parlement et par le
gouvernement
le président de la République a fixé un
cap avec le discours de Belfort en
février 2022 et je comprends que le
Parlement définira à l'été 2023 le cadre
plus général de la politique énergétique
pour les 10 ans à venir dans la loi de
programmation énergie et climat avec des
objectifs précis pour la France et donc
cette loi vient en anticipation pour
donnez les moyens de réaliser la
stratégie qui sera discutée un peu plus
tard le groupe EDF naturellement en tant
que énergéticien est présent dans la
production et la fournisse la fourniture
de plusieurs technologies et dans
plusieurs pays du monde et dispose d'une
expérience et une vision industrielle
pour faire face aux enjeux de
décarbonation et de souveraineté dans
lesquelles le nucléaire est une solution
efficace et compétitive et le défi pour
nous consiste à remplacer la plus grande
pas possible de nos consommations de
pétrole et de gaz par de l'électricité
des carbonée et ça passe par davantage
d'efficacité et de sobriété et au
passage je veux saluer le la
mobilisation des français alors que nous
nous sommes en train de passer la
première vague de froid de l'hiver et la
mobilisation des Français est tout à
fait réelle sur la sobriété et elle nous
aide à passer la première voie de froid
de l'hiver sans problème sur le système
électrique
mais au-delà de cet effort sur la
sobriété naturellement nous devons
travailler sur un niveau de production
qui nous permette de soutenir les
niveaux les besoins en électricité
décarbonée et dans ce cadre le nucléaire
est une technologie absolument
indispensable notamment dans les phases
hivernales et les difficultés que nous
traversons aujourd'hui sur le plan
opérationnel démontre encore plus le
besoin du nucléaire dans les phases
hivernales alors quel est le facteur de
compétitivité du futur parc nucléaire
j'allais dire principalement le temps le
temps que nous mettons à développer dans
des délais de construction raisonnables
vous avez cité des ordres de grandeur
madame la Présidente c'est ce facteur
temps qui est le plus déterminant pour
notre succès futur les nouvelles
réacteurs sont certes plus complexes
également parce qu'ils ont été conçus
d'emblée avec des exigences de sûreté
qui sont qui sont absolus et
naturellement nos procédures se sont
complexifiées par rapport aux années 80
et donc le cas de du projet de loi que
vous examinez il a pour but de
simplifier l'ensemble des procédures et
naturellement EDF ne peut que se
féliciter de ce projet de loi qui doit
nous permettre de réaliser avec succès
le programme du nouveau nucléaire avec
au minimum 6 EPR 2 en commençant par une
première paire qui
tout cela sous réserve du débat public
naturellement
serait réalisé sur le site de Pandi en
Seine-Maritime et le débat public est en
cours les sites candidats pour pour
accueillir ensuite d'autres paires de
PR2 sont effectivement le site de
Gravelines vous l'avez cité madame la
Présidente quand au troisième site nous
avons encore des études techniques à
réaliser pour comparer les mérites
propres de budget et de Tricastin donc
budget dans l'un Tricastin dans la Drôme
et donc les dispositions du projet de
loi qui s'adresse à des projets de
directeurs de Ford puissance E2 à
proximité des centrales nucléaires
existantes aide naturellement à réaliser
les processus les plus rapides possibles
pour nous mettre en mesure de de
construire ces réacteurs sous réserves
du débat public et des procédures en
cours naturellement
dans la continuité de cette loi vous
m'avez posé la question est-ce que c'est
suffisant naturellement nous avons
énormément de travail à faire qui ne
relève pas du législatif nous avons à
travailler sur la filière nous avons à
travailler sur la façon dont l'ensemble
des organisations qui sont ici présentes
travailler ensemble de la façon la plus
fluide possible dans toute la phase de
développement pour ceux qui relèvent du
législatif si j'avais une recommandation
à faire il me semble que il serait utile
que pas forcément dans le cas de cette
projet de ce projet de loi mais dans un
futur proche nous puissions examen
également examiné la faculté
délire ou de désigner des sites qui ne
sont pas à proximité de sites existants
essentiellement pour avoir la chance de
pouvoir développer d'autres types de
réacteurs en France par exemple lorsque
les SMS seront
disponibles ils sont en phase d'études à
ce stade je pense qu'il serait utile de
pouvoir installer ces types de SMR sur
des sites industriels à proximité de
leurs clients
et enfin je me permets de recommander
que dans l'approche que nous avons
des procédures nous intégrions les
besoins la fin de la valve du cycle
parce que l'aval et de la montée à
l'ensemble du cycle du combustible parce
que le cycle du combustible à lui-même
des procédures administratives qui sont
significatives et je pense que si nous
voulons le succès du nucléaire du futur
il faut bien que nous ayons une approche
complète du cycle du nucléaire
voilà ce que je peux vous dire alors
ensuite il y a évidemment énormément de
travail à faire du côté d'EDF et
d'ensemble de la filière et donc je me
suis mis au travail depuis quelques
semaines évidemment l'entreprise était
déjà au travail depuis longtemps j'avais
lors de mon audition eu l'occasion de
mentionner le défi humain que représente
la filière nucléaire je vous confirme
après quelques semaines que c'est bien
là que se trouve le principal défi en
étant capable de régénérer des
compétences d'attirer des compétences
dans la filière nucléaire de faire en
sorte que pour
une visite décennale ou un ou un
chantier de qu'on appelle de grands
carénages qui nécessitent 4000 salariés
à un moment sur un site nous soyons
capables dans le bassin d'emploi de
trouver les 4000 salariés pour une
période qui représente plusieurs mois et
pour le cas d'une construction d'une
nouvelle tranche donc d'un EPR 2 on
parle plutôt de 7500 à 10000 salariés
qui sera nécessaire d'avoir sur un site
pendant une période beaucoup plus longue
donc tout ceci évidemment nécessite un
travail fondamental sur les compétences
sur l'attractivité du métier sur
l'intégration de ces projets dans le
territoire et c'est naturellement dans
cet esprit que nous allons travailler
avec l'ensemble des membres de la
filière
voilà ce que je peux vous dire en propos
liminaire madame la Présidente en
espérant ne pas avoir oublié d'éléments
clés de vos questions je crois que j'ai
répondu sur les sites je crois que j'ai
répondu sur le temps de la stratégie
globale
et sur les souplesse administratives il
y en a pour l'an beaucoup d'autres à
trouver qui ne sont pas forcément de
niveau législatif mais je confirme que
nous allons travailler avec les
administrations de l'État pour faire
faire en sorte que l'ensemble de nos
processus puisse être simplifié au
maximum pour raccourcir l'ensemble des
délais de construction à partir du
moment où on décide de lancer un projet
sur un site et le moment où il est
raccordé au réseau c'est vraiment le
facteur clé de succès de la filière
nucléaire voilà merci madame le
Président
merci tout ce qui n'est pas
réglementaire tout ce qui est
réglementaire peut aussi passer en
législatif pour aller plus vite être
plus sécurisé monsieur dans votre je
vous laisse
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
vous m'avez posé deux types de questions
madame la Présidente tout d'abord une
question relative au projet de loi qui
va être soumis à vos débats et à votre
vote et ensuite les questions plus
ciblées sur les moyens dont dispose
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire notamment
en matière de coercition ou de sanction
liées aux nouveaux projets nucléaires
une question sur laquelle j'essaierai de
vous apporter un éclairage montrant la
manière dont nous utilisons ces moyens
coercitions et ceux qui pourraient
éventuellement découler de la mise en
place du nouveau projet alors tout
d'abord en ce qui concerne le projet de
loi d'accélération nucléaire ce projet
se vise comme comme vous l'avez dit
accélérez la construction des nouveaux
projets de type EPR 2 notamment sur les
sites nucléaires existants je rejoins la
remarque président d'EDF concernant
l'extension éventuelle de ce projet à
d'autres types de réacteur sur d'autres
sites nucléaires puisque c'est
effectivement un sujet qui pourrait
également être pris à bord dans le
projet futur de loi en matière de
développement de nouveaux projets
nucléaires notamment le cas des SMS
alors le projet de loi qui qui vous est
présenté vise à faciliter les procédures
administratives et notamment celles qui
sont relatives à l'environnement et à la
gestion du droit des sols dans une phase
qui est finalement très limitaire à la
construction nucléaire elle-même et ce
projet vise à gagner du temps sur ces
étapes qui sont non nucléaires dans le
projet ces premières étapes sont
essentiellement composées de travaux
permettant de préparer le site avant la
pose du ce qu'on appelle le premier
béton nucléaire qui en fait le T0 à
partir duquel on compte la durée du
projet on décompte la durée du projet
les durées que vous avez indiquées tout
à l'heure correspondent à ce T0 la pose
du premier béton nucléaire ce n'est pas
le premier de la première opération de
travaux
donc le projet de loi en ce sens ne
modifie absolument pas les exigences ni
les procédures existantes en matière de
sûreté nucléaire pour les nouveaux
projets les enjeux de sûreté nucléaires
sont essentiellement portés par
l'autorisation de création de
l'installation qui est dans la demande
sera instruite par l'autorité sûreté
nucléaire suivant le processus actuel et
avec les mêmes étapes de concertation et
d'association du public puisque c'est
une question qu'on m'avait posée sur la
participation de public donc ce volet
dont la SN à la charge n'est absolument
pas impacté par le projet d'accélération
nucléaire c'est surtout le volet en
amont en ce qui concerne toutes les
conditions de mise en état du site pour
pouvoir accueillir le projet du
nucléaire lui-même donc la délivrance de
l'autorisation de création n'est pas sur
le chemin critique du projet et ça c'est
un aimant essentiel qu'il faut bien
vérifier mais je pense que c'est tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que ce
n'est pas le processus de délivrance
d'autorisation de création qui est un
facteur bloquant pour le déroulement du
projet
alors si le projet de loi est bien
évidemment important il n'est pas le
seul élément qui permet d'accélérer un
projet de construction d'installation
nucléaire il n'est pas tout et je
rejoins là également la remorque
présidente d'EDF il y a bien évidemment
un travail en commun à réaliser et un
commun un travail en anticipation à
réaliser pour pouvoir accélérer la
partie industrielle de la construction
nucléaire elle-même
donc indépendamment de des
instructions l'ASN n'attend pas que la
demande d'autorisation de création soit
déposée pour avancer sur ce projet avec
EDF donc nous avons déjà
commencé à travailler avec EDF avec les
équipes d'EDF sur ce que nous appelons
une version préliminaire du rapport de
sûreté qui accompagnera qui est une
pièce essentielle dans le dépôt de la
demande d'autorisation de création donc
nous travaillons alors même que la
demande n'a pas été déposée sur une des
pièces essentielles et nous le faisons
en avec l'appui de l'URSS pour que nous
puissions effectivement
identifier des points durs de manière
elle est traitée avant même que le la
demande soit déposée
de la même manière là encore toujours en
travail anticipation nous sommes
sollicités par framatum qui est un
fabricant essentiel de gros composants
nucléaires pour travailler sur la
qualification des pièces forgées les
plus importantes qui vont permettre la
fabrication des cuves ou la fabrication
des générateurs de vapeurs et cela bien
en amont de du lancement de
l'autorisation du projet c'est un risque
industriel pris par femme atome puisque
la décision n'est pas formellement prise
mais nous avons de notre côté bien
accepté de ne pas bloquer le projet pour
travailler en amont donc voyons il y a
les délais industriels sont l'élément
fondamental dans la conduite du projet
et dans la tenue
de la durée du projet plus peut-être
pour la partie nucléaire que la partie
réglementaire qui s'y attache
alors ce projet de loi ne comporte pas
qu'un titre 1 dont je viens de parler
qui est cela celui de l'accélération des
procédures administratives relatives au
droit du sol mais comporte également un
titre de dont la SN est à l'origine et
qui concerne comme vous l'avez souligné
le parc existant et qui concerne un
point très particulier des dispositions
législatives actuelles relatives aux
décisions qui sont prises à l'issue des
réamens de sûreté notamment à partir du
quatrième règlement de sûreté après 35
années de fonctionnement donc cette
cette disposition qui figure dans le
titre 2 vise à simplifier le dispositif
actuel de décision relative aux
améliorations de sûreté à partir de ce
quatrième examen comme vous le savez
chaque examen fait l'objet d'une partie
de réévaluation de la sûreté des
réacteurs pour pouvoir les amener leur
niveau le plus près possible des
réacteurs de dernière génération donc il
y a un volume assez important de
modification qui permettent de
d'améliorer la sûreté ces améliorations
de sûreté elles ont deux sources
essentielles elles ont une première
source qui vient de l'exploitant
lui-même qui mène le travail
préparatoire au examencurité et qui
propose un certain nombre de
modifications pour améliorer la sûreté
et c'est modifications sont dans le
texte actuel doivent être soumis à
enquête publique pour pouvoir
effectivement les présenter au public et
recueillir leur avis il y a en parallèle
une procédure de d'adoption par la SN de
prescriptions techniques complémentaires
qui résulte bien évidemment des débats
et des discussions techniques que nous
avons à l'exploitant mais le droit en
vigueur ne définit pas l'articulation
entre ces deux procédures et donc ce que
nous proposons à travers le projet de
loi c'est de corriger et de simplifier
le dispositif actuel en reliant
l'enquête publique à l'adoption par
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire des
prescriptions techniques complémentaires
et donc ça ça permettra effectivement
d'avoir une participation du public qui
sera complète et qui comportera à la
fois l'association du public sur les
propositions qui sont formulées par
l'exploitante puisqu'à chaque fois que
ces modifications sont notables il y a
une consultation du public donc le
public reste impliqué sur les
modifications proposées par l'exploitant
mais en plus il sera impliqué par les
modifications supplémentaires proposées
par l'Autorité de sûreté au moment de
l'enquête publique donc ce dispositif
simplifiera le processus actuel et le
rendra plus robuste
il y a une deuxième modification qui qui
est dans ce titre 2 et qui concerne qui
consiste pardon à remplacer une
disposition actuelle qui conduit à
l'arrêt définitif de plein droit d'une
installation nucléaire qui n'a pas
fonctionné pendant deux ans donc c'est
un coup près d'une certaine manière il y
a possibilité de relaxer ce coup près
mais il y a un coup près dans la loi et
là nous proposons que cette disposition
soit remplacée par en fait un acte
positif qui serait un acte de décision
éventuellement de fermeture au regard
des enjeux si ce délai était dépassé et
donc ce n'est que dans ce cas là que la
fermeture serait imposée et la
consultation du public bien évidemment
se fera sur la base du projet de décret
de fermeture puisque ce sera un décret
donc voilà ce qui figure dans le projet
de loi voyez-vous c'est essentiellement
des dispositions en ce qui concerne la
SN dans le titre de qui sont des
dispositions d'allègement et qui n'ont
pas d'impact bien évidemment sur les
projets de nouveau nucléaires
puisqu'elles concernent les
installations en service
vous m'imposez ensuite la question sur
le les moyens de coercition et de
sanctions dont dispose l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire donc effectivement
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire dispose
d'une palette de pouvoir à la fois d'un
jeu d'action d'injonction pardon et de
sanctions qui ont été qui sont
importants et qui ont été renforcés par
la loi tecv avec une possibilité de de
d'astreinte et d'amende pardon
administrative dès lors que nous avons
bien évidemment la vie et l'accord du
Comité des sanctions qui a été mise en
place alors il faut le dire clairement
c'est que ces moyens dont dispose qu'ils
ont importants dont dispose la SN sont
utilisés de manière adaptée au contexte
nucléaire qui est tout à fait différent
de celui des installations classées pour
l'environnement il y a plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'installations
classées il y en revanche que très peu
d'exploitants nucléaires les exploitants
nucléaires sont en général des
exploitants avec une forte structure et
nous avons un dialogue technique
permanent avec les exploitants
nucléaires qui permet de bien calibrer
les dispositions réglementaires ou les
prescriptions que nous imposons ce qui
est assez différent dans le domaine des
installations classées donc c'est ces
moyens de coercition sont mis en oeuvre
de manière relativement modeste en
nombre lorsqu'on est compare au cas des
installations classées par exemple il y
a pas plus d'une dizaine de mise en
demeure qui sont qui sont faites par la
SN par an donc c'est relativement faible
il n'y a depuis 2014 pas eu de
d'exigences de d'exécution de travaux
d'office par exemple donc c'est assez
faible et la commission d'exorcistes des
sanctions depuis sa mise en oeuvre n'a
jamais été sollicité puisque finalement
nous avons toujours réussi à régler les
sujets avant que on en arrive à l'étape
de la sollicitation de la commission des
sanctions
donc il y a relativement rarement des
écarts constaté par rapport aux
obligations réglementaires ou nos
prescriptions de la SN et lorsque ces
écarts sont constatés ils font l'objet
de mise en demeure et les exploitants
règles les problèmes avant l'échéance de
mise en demeure bien évidemment si ce
n'était pas le cas on utiliserait moins
de sanctions alors je ne pense pas que
les projets liés à la relance du
nucléaire change quoi que ce soit cette
situation lorsque l'on regarde le
chantier de le père de Flamanville par
exemple depuis son début nous n'avons
procédé qu'à deux mises en demeure une
mise en demeure pour des raisons de
sûreté une fois que le combustible avait
été approvisionné donc c'est la phase la
plus récente et puis le depuis le début
du chantier une mise en demeure en
termes d'inspection du travail puisque
nous sommes inspecteur du travail
également sur les centrales nucléaires
voilà donc c'est un système un moyen
dont nous disposons on l'utilisera si
besoin mais pour l'instant les choses ne
se passent pas de telle manière qu'il
faille le faire et il faut s'en réjouir
voilà sur les deux questions merci
beaucoup Monsieur François Jacques je me
permets de donner la parole merci même
pardon merci madame la Présidente donc
peut-être rapidement parce que je
partage beaucoup de ce qui a été dit
pour repositionner de luminaires pour
repositionner le CEA dans ce processus
un Willa à la fois une part importante
mais peut-être pas absolument clé par
rapport au projet de loi le CEA est un
organisme de recherche j'allais dire
intégré c'est à dire nous nous
intéressons à l'énergie nucléaire et pas
que nucléaire je voudrais pas empiéter
sur probablement ce qui sera indiqué par
par notre collègue drte mais il est
clair que pour nous
il faut toutes les formes d'énergie des
carbonées il faut le nucléaire il en
faut d'autres et le fait d'avoir
plusieurs formes d'énergie carbonée
décarbonée à combiner ensemble induit un
certain nombre de choses qui expliquent
aussi pourquoi au-delà des recherches
qu'on fait sur le nucléaire on travaille
aussi sur l'hydrogène mais on travaille
aussi sur les batteries mais on
travaille aussi sur les dispositifs de
stockage à tout ce qui va ou les réseaux
intelligents tout ce qui va permettre
j'allais dire fonctionnement harmonieux
du système énergétique dans des
évolutions de paradigme je pense par
rapport à ce qu'il a connu donc vision
intégrée et vous rappeliez lier le titre
de l'organisme qui date maintenant des
années 2010 c'est c'est clairement ça
bon ça c'est un premier linéaire le
deuxième luminaire c'est que on est un
organisme de recherche c'est à dire que
à la fois
on a une vision d'ensemble sur toutes
les questions nucléaires de Lamon à
Laval alors que c'est peut-être la mine
mais enfin en tout cas sur la mont du
cycle sur les réacteurs et sur la valse
du cycle en particulier on est on est
présent et et je reprends ce que disait
pas énormément en termes de cette
absolument important d'avoir cette
vision complète du site on est parfois
obsédé par des questions pardon de le
dire comme ça mais obsédé par des
questions de réacteurs et on fait des
réacteurs sans se préoccuper du cycle et
auront les a fait pour le cycle enfin je
reviens pas des choses que j'ai eu de
l'occasion de développer dans d'autres
dans d'autres enceintes donc c'est
extrêmement c'est extrêmement important
et donc nous avons cette compétence de
recherche qui tangente
mais qui ne va pas jusqu'à l'ingénierie
je crois qu'il faut aussi qu'on soit
clair là-dessus c'est à dire que nous ne
sommes pas les les concepteurs des des
produits industriels on peut être aller
très très très proche de la conception
industrielle d'ailleurs dans ce
domaine-là comme dans tous les autres
domaines d'activités si vous pensez à la
microélectronique on est on est en
interface ultime quasiment avec
esthétique sur le sur le développement
des puces mais à un moment il y a eu un
passage de responsabilité soit vers
l'ingénierie soit vers l'industriel ça
c'était pour qualifier un peu nos
limites et j'en viens la réponse à votre
question dans un instant madame la
Présidente
faisant un dernier petit point qui est
celui
de des compétences qu'on a par rapport à
cette loi et de ce qu'on peut dire sur
la loi j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger
avec monsieur le rapporteur là-dessus
donc nous on n'est pas évidemment pas
concerné au premier chef donc je ne
prétendrai pas juger de de la pertinence
juridique du texte sauf que l'intention
générale qui est que nous n'avons pas de
temps à perdre qu'il faut trouver
utiliser comme cet édit tous les leviers
qui vont nous permettre de raccourcir
les processus me semble évidemment
évidemment majeur alors maintenant j'en
viens au rôle du CEA en tant que dans
tout ce process de reprise du nucléaire
j'allais dire qu'il est il a on peut le
divisé de diverses manières mais il a
deux aspects il a un premier aspect qui
est vraiment d'apporter le soutien à la
filière tel qu'elle est aujourd'hui et
telle qu'elle va évoluer qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire apporter le soutien à la
filière ça veut dire que il y a un socle
de compétences et d'installation au sein
du CEA qui sont les voies de recours
quand des difficultés surgissent dans
l'exploitation industrielle donc on l'a
on l'a pratiqué récemment sur un
réacteur de type EPR pas forcément
installé en France enfin pas installer
en France ou par rapport à un certain
nombre de difficultés qu'on a pu
connaître c'est bien vers le CEA qu'on
s'est tourné
et je crois à la satisfaction des uns et
des autres parce qu'il a apporté des
réponses là ou d'autres non n'importe
pas bon donc ça c'est notre métier c'est
vraiment ce qui est clé c'est vraiment
ce en quoi on peut contribuer au parc
actuel et je pense qu'il faut y être
extrêmement vigilant parce que si vous
voulez les shorts de choses qui quand
elle ne servent pas on dit qu'elle coûte
mais quand on ne les a pas on est bien
embêtés donc ça ça vraiment je vous je
sais que je vous savais que je Martelle
ce message de d'audition en audition
mais je j'y insiste particulièrement et
peut-être que le seul petit que dit-il
que je peux apporter par rapport à ça en
terme d'ingénierie alors non pas pour se
faire la grenouille qui se fait plus
grosse que le bœuf c'est-à-dire
revendiquer des choses sur les mais je
pense que on a vu que beaucoup des
problèmes qu'on a eu sur les projets
nucléaires et je balaye devant la porte
j'en ai un chez moi qui s'appelle le
réacteur Jules Robbins donc je balaye
devant mes propres difficultés
d'ingénierie est souvent liée à
peut-être parfois un peu du Brice un peu
un peu un peu de d'ingénierie un peu
compliqué et un peu de défaut
d'anticipation d'un certain nombre de
problèmes qui pourraient venir derrière
je ne parle que pour moi
et ça je pense que ça veut dire que
peut-être y a-t-il un lien un peu plus
fort à faire entre une générique et
recherche pour anticiper un certain
nombre de choses mais c'est pas pour
aller sur un terrain qui n'est pas le
nôtre mais mais voilà ça c'est un
premier point ça vaut pour le parc en le
parc en fonctionnement ça vaut
évidemment pour les EPR à venir dans
dans le même cycle de d'appui la
deuxième partie je vais aller très très
vite mais comme lucrément de l'a évoqué
j'en dis un mot la deuxième partie pour
pour faire une division un peu un peu
hâtive de nos activités c'est évidemment
de préparer ou d'ouvrir des voies
différentes et on va être là typiquement
sur ce qu'on appelle les petits
réacteurs mais enfin globalement tout ce
qu'on peut appeler innovation dans le
domaine nucléaire d'ailleurs ça peut
être des réacteurs ça peut aussi être du
cycle et je je n'insiste pas sur les
subtils du Hans entre les petits les
Smalls les advance enfin bon mais mais
peu importe sachez simplement que
là-dessus on est complètement en
articulation avec EDF qui est le chef de
fil sur les SMS donc mais c'est-à-dire
les petits classiques quoi donc New
World pour ne pas le nommer je rejoins
complètement ce que disait l'ukramont
sur le fait que à un moment dans les
paradigmes énergétiques de demain si ces
réacteurs là pour être clair on n'est
pas capable de les installer ailleurs
que sur des endroits où il y a déjà des
installations nucléaires ça ne va pas
avoir beaucoup de sens donc donc on a un
sujet et je pense que ce sujet là va
pointer avec tout à fait de manière tout
à fait limpide donc ça c'est la partie
small et sur la partie advance alors là
vous êtes sur des choses beaucoup plus
futuristes futuriste enfin des choses
plus avancées ça va être de la 4e
génération ça va être des selfies ça va
être tout ce que vous voulez qui vont
être justement des choses qui
intrinsèquement devraient nous permettre
de mieux traiter le cycle à condition
qu'on oublie pas le cycle c'est-à-dire à
condition qu'on ne fasse pas de réacteur
sans le cycle qui est quand même un des
péchés majeurs dont nous avons coutume
en France et mon organisme y compris
tout ça pour finir et je j'en ai presque
fini pour dire que en plus ça veut dire
que par rapport à toute l'usage du
nucléaire ne restons pas focalisé sur
l'électrification et sur les la seule
électricité nous aurons des besoins en
chaleur
il y aura de la décarbonation de la
chaleur qui ne sera pas facile à faire
sur un centre de grands process
industriel c'est aussi ce que disait le
président Raymond en terme de la
capacité à combiner des
usages de réacteurs et d'autres usages
hydrogène mais pas d'hydrogène je cite
toujours
docimico le le chimiste américain qui
commence à se poser la question de
savoir s'il va pas installer un réacteur
sur un de ces sites industriels pour
justement obtenir de l'achat et c'est de
la chaleur qu'il vise c'est pas c'est
pas forcément que de que de
l'électricité donc là dessus on est en
appui et pour finir et pardon d'avoir
été un peu long madame la Présidente je
dirais que par rapport au projet de loi
je peux que souscrire alors je veux pas
de compétences sur ce que toi tu as pu
dire mais je peux ce que souscrire
modestement à ce que disait le président
Raymond c'est à dire que c'est un
ingrédient c'est certainement un
ingrédient important mais il va falloir
qu'on réalise beaucoup d'ingrédients
pour faire en sorte que que tout ça
converge et et contiennent des délais
qui faut qu'on se le dise que ce soit
des EPERS au milieu de la décennie 2030
que ce soit un petit SMS
également au début de la décennie de bus
30 sont des choses qui sont quand même
ambitieuses voilà merci madame la
Présidente
merci beaucoup nous vous excusez pas de
nous apporter toutes ces informations je
vais me tourner vers monsieur Durot pour
Orano sur les sujets de cycles justement
merci Madame ma présidente
et messieurs les sénateurs donc juste
pour rappeler corano c'est l'entreprise
française qui se situe sur l'ensemble du
cycle donc par le cycle on couvre ce qui
démarre au niveau de la mine donc il y
en a plus en France nous en avons à
l'étranger
bien évidemment après toutes les
processus de transformation chimique
pour pouvoir passer au processus de
transformation physique et
d'enrichissement de l’uranium pour le
mollet dans les cons dans les réacteurs
et après tout la vanne du cycle qui
consiste essentiellement à s'assurer du
traitement et potentiellement recyclage
c'est une des caractéristiques
françaises sur lesquelles je reviendrai
du cycle pour ce faire juste pour
apaiser nos grandeurs donc Orano c'est
environ 17000 collaborateurs dont 13500
en France
pour 4,7 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
alors le on a beaucoup parlé du cycle
effectivement notre conviction profonde
c'est que le succès du nucléaire en
France pour les années à venir et bien
il ne pourrait être rassuré que si les
constructeurs de nouveaux réacteurs
s'inscrivent dans une stratégie
d'ensemble du cycle qui couvre à la fois
l'approvisionnement on uranium enrichi
c'est-à-dire l'amont et les solutions à
retenir pour la gestion des combustibles
c'est-à-dire l'aval qui sont les deux
principaux métiers du groupe Orano on en
a d'autres
et je le dis et je le rappelle la France
est vraiment l'une des rares nations un
dispositif à disposer d'une maîtrise
industrielle de l'intégralité de la
chaîne de valeur du nucléaire ce qui
constitue d'ailleurs un de ces éléments
fondamentaux et essentiels de la
souveraineté énergétique
alors sur l'amour du cycle
en partant après la mine je rappelle
juste corano a fait le choix d'investir
5 milliards d'euros ces 10 dernières
années dans le renouvellement de son
outil industriel sur la plateforme du
Tricastin qui dispose ainsi d'une des
usines les plus modernes au monde il y a
peu d'acteurs à la fois pour la
conversion et l'enrichissement la
tension qu'on peut observer sur les
marchés dernièrement très directement
relié à la crise et à la guerre que
pratique la Russie en Ukraine fait que
il y a une montée des cours à la fois
sur la conversion et l'enrichissement
c'est un véritable enjeu pour nous
et pour l'indépendance énergétique de la
France de s'assurer que au-delà de la
maîtrise de ces établisses on soit
capable non seulement de conserver mais
potentiellement des temps dans les
capacités de production de nos usines
d'enrichissement en France à la fois en
se projetant sur le long terme mais
aussi pour être certain d'assurer une
capacité de réponse en matière
d'approvisionnement pour l'ensemble du
monde occidental pas uniquement la
France dans ce contexte géopolitique on
est attentif bien évidemment à
l'évolution du marché et aux attentes de
nos clients donc sous réserve
d'engagement de long terme de leur part
que nous sommes en train de regarder de
tester nous envisageons d'augmenter nos
capacités d'enrichissement jusqu'à
30%, ce qui est énorme vous rapportez ça
au niveau des montants d'investissement
que je vous ai indiqué pour répondre aux
besoins des clients qui souhaiteraient
d'uranium naturel en Russie
depuis le mois de mars nos équipes
travaillent sur différents scénarios que
ce soit en France ailleurs en Europe aux
États-Unis mais même le scénario le plus
rapide qui serait l'extension de notre
usine actuelle dans le rugissement
Georges Besse 2
et nous avons d'ailleurs d'ores et déjà
lancé le processus de concertation en
saisissant en acndp les choix qui seront
retenus sont soumis aux enjeux de
planning le coût et de
contractualisation des clients
autrement dit et comme indiqué le
président de roguc les temps industriels
existent
si on prend une décision en 2023 le
premier module sachant que ce sont des
usines modulaires pourra fonctionner en
2028 pas avant et encore en marchant
extrêmement rapidement
du côté de l'aval du cycle
l'industrie française et le leader
mondial de traitement recyclage des
combustibles nucléaires usés c'est une
technologie qui permet à la fois
d'économiser les ressources naturelles
en recyclant la matière énergétique qui
est encore contenue dans le combustible
nucléaire et en sortie de réacteur
de plus cette technique réduit fortement
la radio toxicité et le volume des
déchets nucléaires et permet d'en
assurer le confinement sous une forme
sur et stable à long terme
hormis les États-Unis
toutes les grandes puissances nucléaires
civiles comme le Japon la Chine l'Inde
et la Russie ou envisager et mis en
oeuvre à des niveaux de maturité
différents le traitement recyclage aucun
autre pays n'a cependant maîtrisé son
déploiement industriel complet
toutefois à la différence des usines de
la montre dont je vous ai rappelé
l'important investissement et
renouvellement ces dernières années
celle de Laval du cycle c'est à dire
essentiellement les usines de lag et le
Melox du côté de Marcoul on démarrait
dans les années 90 et la question de
leur renouvellement va devoir être
décidé au cours des prochaines années et
dans un futur proche
vous m'avez posé la question madame la
Présidente de la disponibilité en France
des compétences nécessaires du côté du
cycle alors les enjeux de court terme
sont directement traités heureusement
pour pouvoir faire fonctionner en toute
sûreté sécurité nos usines donc que ce
soit de manière très directe à
destination de Rano nous avons créé un
campus max du côté de l'usine de menoc
une école des métiers au Tricastin un
certain nombre d'actions qui visent à
augmenter notre notoriété
ainsi que renforcer l'apprentissage et
le levier de recrutement et pour
illustrer mon propos juste en tant que
donc patron de l'ingénierie dorano je
dois recruter un peu moins de 400
personnes cette année vous imaginez bien
que Ingénieur vous imaginez bien que ça
n'est pas simple et ça suppose de
pouvoir s'assurer de l'attractivité du
métier et des perspectives qu'on peut
donner notamment aux jeunes on est par
ailleurs appliqué dans un certain nombre
de formations sur les métiers en tension
c'est à dire l'un des ingénieurs on a
besoin
un certain nombre de colle bleue et très
directement le pôle d'excellence de
soudage à chapeau où nous sommes
impliqués aux côtés d'EDF naval Group et
des chantiers maritimes de Normandie on
est une belle illustration pour
ré-acquérir un certain nombre de
compétences
en revanche tout comme pour la
construction de pairs il est évident que
au moment du renouvellement des usines
de Laval du cycle
la question des
compétences et notamment des Mains
d'Oeuvres disponibles sur les deux sites
et notamment celui de lag sera colossal
et devrait être proprement adressé en
matière de réponse
pour revenir plus spécifiquement sur le
projet de loi de simplification sur le
nucléaire donc je ne peux bien
évidemment que saluer l'ambition qui
vise à accélérer les procédures en cas
de décision de construction de nouveaux
réacteurs je m'inscris complètement dans
ce qui a été dit à la fois par le
président Raymond et l'administrateur
général à savoir que ça n'est pas
simplement des réacteurs
électronucléaires qu'il faut regarder et
pas forcément uniquement à côté du site
des ind très clairement il serait
pertinent que les dispositions relatives
à l'accélération des procédures liées à
la construction
descendre l'ensemble des ouvrants
acteurs donc que ce soit des SMS ou que
ce soit des réacteurs plus avancés et ça
n'est pas juste une vision
en termes d'illustration de propos je
rappelle que le projet France 2030 est
un appel à projet pour la construction
de nouveaux types de réacteurs et si on
veut s'assurer que ce type de
démonstrateur puisse voir le jour que ce
soit proche d'une installation nucléaire
ou éventuellement sur un site
indépendant il faut pouvoir aussi
envisager une accélération rapide pour
pouvoir développer ce type de
technologie
mais aussi ça peut bien évidemment
s'entendre et s'étendre pour l'ensemble
des installations du cycle du
combustible et je vous ai donné quelques
points d'illustration en matière des
besoins auxquels nous pourrions avoir à
faire face l'objectif de l'extension est
donc double c'est à la fois une exigence
d'intelligibilité du droit et en même
temps de prise en compte de l'ensemble
des besoins
le robot de la filière nucléaire
très bien le message le message est
passé monsieur vérande pour RTE
je vous laisse clôturer merci merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices les sénateurs
alors avis d'être auditionné aujourd'hui
RTA trois rôles le premier qu'on connaît
bien en ce moment qui est celui
d'exploiter le système électrique quel
que soit son état le deuxième qui est
développé notre grand réseau national
qui va permettre de connecter notamment
les réacteurs nucléaires
les centres de consommation les
renouvelables et le troisième qui est de
faire un certain nombre d'études de
nature
prospective ou prévisionnelle parce que
pas exactement la même chose et j'ai
l'impression que votre première question
sur la solidité du mix se rattache
plutôt à cette à cette mission là alors
qu'est-ce qu'un mix solide la première
chose c'est un mix qui nous permet
d'atteindre nos objectifs climatiques et
donc qui se projette dans une
dans un monde électrique différent
d'aujourd'hui puisque l'électricité
concentre beaucoup de nos débats
citoyens pour autant l'électricité c'est
25% c'est un quart de l'énergie qu'on
consomme donc elle est omniprésente mais
pas dominante aujourd'hui dans notre mix
on doit se projeter dans un monde où on
est sorti complètement des énergies
fossiles et elle aujourd'hui c'est 60%
en France de consommation énergétique
donc ça va de toute façon nous projeter
avec des consommations d'électricité
croissante à horizon à horizon moyen
long terme et
c'est dans ce contexte là qu'il faut
intégrer la construction de nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires on sait aussi un
mix qui doit garantir la sécurité
d'approvisionnement
et qui doit être compétitif d'un point
de vue économique alors on a rendu en
fin 2021 puis début 2022 les résultats
de nos scénarios 2050 qui ont été un
très gros travail qui nous a mobilisé
deux ans et qui a mobilisé également
tout notre écosystème puisque tout ça
est fait en concertation avec l'ensemble
des personnes intéressées
il y a deux il y a deux grilles de
lecture potentiellement différentes de
ces scénarios alors la première c'est de
regarder d'essayer de voir ce qui oppose
les filières moi c'est pas celle que je
privilégie parce qu'en réalité
nucléaire renouvelable rénovation
thermique rien industrialisation réseau
stockage
c'est la même structure économique
beaucoup d'investissement au départ et
des coûts de fonctionnement plus faibles
après
c'est une même problématique de facteur
temps je pense que ça a été mentionné
par toutes les personnes qui ont parlé
avant moi et c'est absolument essentiel
nous avons une problématique temps c'est
à dire que entre le moment on va appuyer
sur l'accélérateur et le moment où
concrètement notre mix énergétique va
changer il va se passer plusieurs années
minimum et puis ce sont des solutions
qui va bien falloir faire fonctionner
ensemble
dans les scénarios effectivement dans la
famille où il y a réinvestissement dans
le parc nucléaire il y a différents
rythmes qui sont proposés
le premier c'est important d'avoir en
tête que un scénario ou entre guillemets
ont construitait six nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires au rythme de un une perte
tous les cinq ans en commençant à
l'horizon 2035 donc 2035 2040 2045 est
un scénario
qui à terme devient majoritaire en
énergie renouvelable pour atteindre les
objectifs climatiques pourquoi parce que
dans nos scénarios on considère pour le
nucléaire mais c'est vrai également pour
les autres filières que les
installations industrielles à un moment
sont mises à l'arrêt pour des raisons
d'âge
c'est vrai pour les réacteurs nucléaires
de deuxième génération qui ont été
construits de manière très concentrée
entre la fin des années 70 et le début
des années 90 c'est vrai aussi pour les
éoliennes qu'on construit pour les
éoliennes en mer pour les panneaux
solaires c'est vrai pour les
installations de réseaux c'est vrai pour
toutes les installations industrielles
alors on peut en prolonger la durée de
vie mais quand on fait une prospective
énergétique on est obligé de se
confronter à ça et donc un premier point
c'est que si on est entre guillemets que
sur 6 réacteurs nucléaires de troisième
génération
nous serons dans une situation où pour
boucler nos trajectoires il faudra
mettre beaucoup d'énergie renouvelable
à tel point que nous on considère pas
techniquement que il y a d'un côté les
scénarios sans nouveau nucléaire et de
l'autre les scénarios avec de nouveaux
nucléaire un scénario que nous on a
appelé N1 avec ses 6 réacteurs c'est un
scénario qui que pour faire fonctionner
nous devons accompagner de beaucoup de
renouvelables et donc on doit réussir à
peu près tous les paris technologiques
qui sont associés au scénario à haute
part en énergie renouvelable et au
travail que nous avions fait avec
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
c'est pas exactement le cas par contre
si on est dans le scénario d'après qui
est lui à 14
qu'on a travaillé largement dans notre
concertation c'est pas c'est pas le cas
dans la mesure où avec un socle d'une
quarantaine de gigawatts de centrale
nucléaire maintenu durablement horizon
2040 2050 2060 une partie des besoins de
flexibilité sont réellement traités par
le nucléaire et donc vous avez besoin de
beaucoup moins de moyens de et donc là
vous avez une différence de nature
technique et donc le la différence entre
6 et 14 elle est pas uniquement
symbolique c'est pas juste un écart d'un
de numérotation des scénarios ça renvoie
à des choses qui sont plus fondamentales
dans la façon dont on va construire et
faire fonctionner notre notre système
électrique effectivement 14 quand on
regarde l'ensemble des contraintes et ça
le travail a été mené durant les besoins
de concertation avec les opérateurs
industriels de la de la filière
s'aperçoit que l'accélération elle ne
porte pas en réalité ou pas beaucoup sur
la période 2030 2040 mais après c'est à
dire que si on veut avoir la faculté
d'avoir reconstitué la filière et tenir
compte du retour d'expérience des
premières tranches pour les secondes
alors le scénario N2 a 14 réacteurs
nucléaires réussi à accélérer mais c'est
visible dans la décennie 2040 2050 et
pas avant et donc on en revient à ma
question de facteurs temps
voilà pour ces questions de mix mais si
vous voulez je pourrais bien sûr dire
développer dans le cadre des questions
alors est-ce que c'est propre à la
France d'avoir de telles délais je pense
que si on se dit que l'objectif est
d'avoir des réacteurs nucléaires
opérationnels en 2035 2037 c'est
pour raisonnablement ambitieux et donc
ça me semble pas propre à la France
vous avez cité dans votre dans votre
question madame la Présidente le passage
de 6 à 8 ans dans les années 70-80 à 12
à 16 ans actuellement mais en réalité
les réacteurs de la deuxième génération
du palier M4 ont déjà été avaient déjà
des délais de construction beaucoup plus
long que ceux du palier 900 MW des
années 70 donc je dirais que que c'est
pas une fonction où tout le programme de
deuxième génération a été construit très
rapidement et brutalement aujourd'hui il
y aura eu une énorme marche non c'est
pas comme ça et je pense pas qu'on
arrivera le projet de loi mais je vais y
revenir va permettre d'accélérer un
certain nombre de choses mais je ne
je pense pas qu'il va nous conduire à
revenir au rythme de construction des
années 70 ce qui est plus propre à la
France en réalité c'est le délai de
construction des énergies renouvelables
mais bon ça c'est un autre projet de loi
donc je ne me
m'exprimerai pas là dessus aujourd'hui
alors est-ce que ça vient tard c'était
votre question
moi je pense que c'est c'est le bon
moment et lorsque dans les scénarios
nous avons
dit qu'il fallait décider rapidement
c'était en ayant en tête la nécessité
que ce soit dans les scénarios où on
choisissait beaucoup de renouvelables ou
des scénarios ont choisissait des mixes
durablement renouvelables plus nucléaire
d'enclencher la démarche industrielle
qui nous conduit à prévoir des mises en
service pas trop éloignés et le fait que
nous ayons aujourd'hui cette table ronde
montre que la situation a changé depuis
que nous avons publié des scénarios donc
moi je pense que c'est en fait le bon
moment
lorsque nous avons publié en octobre
2021 je pense qu'on s'attendait pas à ce
que aussi rapidement un cap soit soit
fixé le cap est clair sur le sur le sur
le type de scénario donc oui bien
évidemment vous avez raison il faut il
faut le traduire dans la loi de
programme et donc il faut qu'elle soit
votée dans les adopter pour clarifier
cette situation dans les meilleurs
délais mais pour autant on a quand même
l'impression que l'alignement et la
nécessité
a été largement partagé à l'occasion de
la publication de nos scénarios et on
s'en félicite et pour finir est-ce que
ce projet de loi est utile et bien oui
il est utile ne serait-ce que pour tenir
le timing qui est actuellement dans les
scénarios ou dans les annonces du
gouvernement pour être pour de nouveaux
réacteurs soient en service en 2035 2037
j'ai l'impression qu'il faut absolument
ce projet de loi
je pense que l'horizon 2035 il était
dans son rétro planning tel qu'il figure
dans les documents publiés par l'État
nécessitait des saisines de la
Commission nationale du débat public en
2021 donc comme on est en 2022 voyez que
pour tenir l'horizon 2035 et bien on a
l'impression qu'il faut effectivement
réaliser et mettre en oeuvre les
dispositions qui sont prévues par le
projet de loi donc pour le nucléaire
mais je dirais la même chose pour les
renouvelables ou pour le réseau nous
avons besoin d'accélération et donc de
ce type de mesure qui tout en permettant
une association du public
d'aller plus rapidement et à la hauteur
de nos enjeux énergétiques merci
beaucoup
bien merci à vous cinq il reste quelques
petits points qu'on pas été abordés je
pense aux capacités de financement ou
perspectives de financement de ce
programme
et puis je rappelle y compris pour
Monsieur Veyron que pour l'instant les
décrets prévoit toujours la fermeture de
réacteurs de réacteurs donc je sais pas
si c'est difficile d'écrire des crèmes
et en tout cas pour l'instant on est
dans l'accélération des ouvertures mais
on a toujours en ligne de mire la
fermeture la fermeture de certains je
vais laisser la parole aux deux
rapporteur donc a commencé par Daniel
Gremillet puis Pascal Martin oui merci
Madame la friante mes chers collègues à
mon tour je souhaite remercier nos
intervenants de leur participation à
cette table ronde mais après vous avoir
écouté dans un premier temps je serais
tenté de dire on a déjà quelques
planètes alignées plutôt qu'une table
ronde de mémoire sénatoriale
c'est une première que
de vous réunir tous aujourd'hui et
effectivement la mémoire sénatoriale
s'écrit elle aussi au temps long donc je
crois effectivement d'avoir cette
dimension aujourd'hui et absolument
formidable
je remercie aussi particulièrement parce
que le Martin qui est rapporteur pour
avis de sa présence mais surtout du
travail qu'on fait ensemble dans les
différents auditions comme vous le savez
nous préparons actuellement l'examen du
très attendu au projet de loi
d'accélération du nucléaire nous avons
largement entamé nos auditions et avons
entendu juste avant vous devant le
groupe d'études d'énergie Michel Badré
président de la formation la Commission
nationale de débat public chargé du
débat public de sur la construction du
nouveau nucléaire mais aussi
ceux de Pandi en particulier
s'agissant de la méthode retenue par le
gouvernement je regrette qu'il légifère
dans le désordre pour bien faire il
aurait fallu soumettre à l'examen
parlementaire la programmation puis le
nucléaire puis le renouvelable je
déplore également qu'il impose d'examen
très serré puisque ce texte sera examiné
en séance publique mi-janvier plus
d'organisation plus d'anticipation et
plus de co-construction aurait été
nécessaire sur un sujet aussi important
où est la méthode proxy promise par le
gouvernement concernant l'évolution
proposée par le gouvernement nous ne
pouvons que nous réjouir de la relance
du nucléaire tout en rappelant que cette
relance intervient tardivement et
partiellement les annonces du
gouvernement font pour l'instant
davantage office de rattrapage que de
relance je rappelle que la commission
des affaires économiques alerté sur
l'impact de la crise de la covid-19 sur
les prix des énergies et le décalage du
programme d'arrêt de tranche dès son
rapport sur cette crise de juin 2020 et
notre président devient de le rappeler à
juste titre il y a des décisions sur
lesquelles on en est toujours pas revenu
elle est aussi elle a aussi alerté sur
l'impact de la guerre russe et en
Ukraine et du phénomène de corrosion
sous contrainte dès son rapport sur le
risque de blackout de février 2022 que
j'ai fait avec mes collègues comme l'a
indiqué notre Président nous avons aussi
plaidé pour une relance complète du
cnucléaire dans notre rapport de juillet
2022 la position de notre commission a
donc été celle de la constance avant et
bien souvent contre celle du
gouvernement ce ne fut pas simple de
décaler de 10 ans le calendrier de
fermeture des réacteurs existants dans
la loi énergie climat de 2019 ce ne fut
pas simple d'interdire toute fermeture
de réacteurs dès qu'elle présente un
risque de sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement la sûreté nucléaire
ou les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans la loi climat résilience de 2021
nous étions bien seul à l'époque
c'est tout des fois que je souhaitais
rappeler parce que on vient de pas de
nulle part et c'est aussi un travail
parlementaire très profond qui a été
fait sur le dossier énergétique mais ce
sont de remuer le passé pour évoquer
l'avenir c'est ce que je vais faire
maintenant celui de la filière nucléaire
et au-delà de notre compétitivité
économique et notre vie sociale c'est
pourquoi je compléterai brièvement les
questions posées par notre présidente en
premier lieu je souhaiterais que le PDG
d'EDF nous indique ou en est la
résolution du phénomène de corrosion
sous contrainte avez-vous une visibilité
sur les indisponibilités prévisibles
pour les mois prochains un mot sur
l'application du programme Excel serait
également précieux sommes-nous prêts sur
le plan de la formation et des
compétences pour la construction
annoncée de nouveaux réacteurs c'est un
point information compétences qui a été
abordé par tous
c'est un sujet de préoccupation relevé
par notre commission dans son rapport
sur la filière nucléaire de de juillet
dernier un mot aussi sur la modalité du
financement je reviens sur une
non-réponse de notre Présidente je crois
que c'est vraiment important la Cour des
comptes à Clermont indiqué que DF ne
pourrait financer seul cette relance de
nucléaire qu'en pensez-vous faut-il
préférer un financement par fond propre
par emprunt par prix régulé ou encore
par participation de consommateurs
électro intensifs comme pratiqué
ailleurs en Europe dans deux pays
européens notamment en ce qu'en lieu je
voudrais que la SN
nous indique son opinion sur les EPR 2
et les CMR qui pourraient être
construits sont-ils plus sûrs que les
réacteurs plus anciens
et sont-ils moins producteurs de déchets
je m'interroge notamment sur les risques
liés à la construction des nouveaux
réacteurs des extensions des sites
existants impliquent-elles des risques
cumulés dont la gestion par la
collectivité territoriale ou les
services des concentrés concernés ne
doit pas être simple les implantations
d'installation en bord de mer
présente-t-elle des risques spécifiques
liés par exemple à la submersion ou
l'érosion si oui comment les prévenir
concernant le ce j'aimerais que vous
nous précisiez si la recherche nucléaire
lui semble pouvoir être davantage prises
en compte dans le projet de loi au-delà
de la construction de père de peut-on
développer des SMS et peut-on y
promouvoir le couplage nucléaire
hydrogène
pour ce qui concerne le groupe Orano je
souhaiterais qu'il fasse état de son
opinion sur le devenir des usines de
retraitement et recyclage l'État ne
doit-il pas prendre en compte une
décision sur les pérennisations car on
sait que ces installations arriveront à
50e année de fonctionnement des 2040
il s'agissant en fin de RTU il serait
surpris et sûrement déçu si je ne
peux pas résister à la question que tous
mes collègues et beaucoup de Français se
posent quels sont vos prévisions sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement électrique
combien de délestage pouvez-vous
imaginer en fonction des prévisions
météo que vous avez déjà avoir
pouvez-vous nous préciser les périodes
et les régions les plus critiques voilà
madame la Présidente chers collègues et
à tous nos invités un grand merci pour
vos réponses Monsieur Le Normand
rapporteur
habitant de Seine-Maritime maritime
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
madame la Présidente je vous remercie
très sincèrement pour l'invitation à
cette table ronde un merci également les
les 5 intervenants vous l'avez dit
Daniel l'a également dit en tant que
rapporteur pour avis sur le projet de
loi relatif à l'accélération des
procédures liées à la construction de
nouvelles installations
je me concentrerai sur le contenu même
de ce texte et vous partagerez quelques
observations et interrogations issues du
cycle d'audition que nous avons commencé
la semaine passée dans un excellent
climat avec Daniel grimillet tout
d'abord peut-être rappeler vous l'avez
fait de la nécessité de ce texte et qui
répond en partie
aux enjeux qui sont devant nous mais
peut-être rappeler au collègues
l'ambition ce texte il est enfermé
notamment son titre premier il ne
concerne un que les réacteurs
électroniques électronucléaires
de ils ne vise que les projets situés à
proximité de sites nucléaires existants
et enfin les demandes d'autorisation
concernent que celles qui sont déposées
dans une durée de 15 ans
à compter de la promulgation de ce
projet de loi donc c'est c'est une
ambition certes mais qui reste mesurée
une observation tout d'abord l'étude
d'impact du projet de loi est à mes yeux
très lacunaire
aucune estimation du gain de temps
global pour la construction des nouveaux
opère n'est fournis par le gouvernement
c'est un sujet qu'on a évoqué mais je me
permets d'y revenir c'est dommageable
pour un texte dont l'ambition est
justement de gagner du temps je rappelle
accélération des procédures la première
question est donc basique avez-vous une
idée je me permets d'insister du gain de
temps permis par ce texte et si oui
pouvez-vous nous préciser à quel stade
de la construction nous verrezacteurs et
pour quel type d'autorisation ces gains
de temps interviennent ma deuxième
question porte sur la notion qui fait
débat de proximité immédiate des
centrales existantes utilisées
à l'article premier concrètement là
aussi j'essaie d'être très terre à terre
mais ces questions légitimes se posent à
nous à quelle distance maximale des
centrales existantes les nouveaux opère
seront-ils construits pour éviter des
contentieux et c'est aussi l'un des
objets ce projet de loi c'est de réduire
le plus possible et contentieux ne
voterai ne vaudrait-il pas mieux définir
cette notion de proximité immédiate par
exemple en considérant que cette notion
s'étend comme une zone
d'implantation ne nécessitant pas de
modifications des plans particuliers
d'intervention je pense que ça ça serait
plus facile à
éviterait des contentieux enfin
l'article 4 du projet de loi reporte
dans le temps la réalisation des
bâtiments à plus fort en jeu de sûreté
car il faudra maintenant attendre
l'octroi de l'autorisation de création
par l'ASN pour commencer ces travaux
monsieur le Président de la SN l'a
évoqué ma dernière question sera donc là
aussi très directe s'agit-il de tirer la
conséquence des difficultés initiales de
Flamanville en particulier de
l'insuffisance des études avant projet
comme la révéler la Cour des comptes en
2020 je vous remercie
le rapporteur je vais sur le même
process vous redonner la parole à tous
voilà avec des questions directes qui
vous ont été posées monsieur le
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur les rapporteurs pour pour vos
questions
je vais peut-être commencer par un bref
point sur sur le raccordement au réseau
progressif de nos réacteurs après
traitement des problèmes de corrosion
sous contrainte donc à ce jour nous
avons 41 réacteurs connectés au réseau
une puissance
productible de 41,3 gigawatts
ce qui nous a permis avec le soutien des
Français auxquels je rend hommage à
nouveau qui font preuve de sobriété de
passer cette première phase de froid
sans difficulté sur le sur le réseau
nous aurons trois réacteurs
supplémentaires connectés d'ici de Noël
qui sont évidemment en cours de
processus de finalisation soit de visite
décennale soit de retour pour travaux
autre que la visite décennale qui sont
les réacteurs de Gravelines 3 de
Saint-Alban 2 et de Dampierre 2
et enfin nous travaillons sur Gravelines
4 pour être recouplé au réseau le plus
tôt possible en 2023
donc voilà notre plan de reconnection au
réseau sur le sur les chantiers de
corrosion sous contrainte sur lesquels
j'ai évidemment dès les premiers jours
de mon mandat travaillé avec les équipes
sur place d'ailleurs j'étais à
Flamanville le premier jour de mon
mandat les deux premiers jours de mon
mandat
nous avons
enfin l'entreprise
en peu de temps identifier le problème
travailler sur les instruments de mesure
qui permettent de le caractère le
caractériser de façon non destructive
c'est-à-dire ne pas être obligé de
couper les tuyaux pour être simple pour
pour caractériser les problèmes mis en
place un processus de réparation tout
cela avec une collaboration que je salue
avec avec l'Autorité de sûreté nous
allons le plus vite possible je peux
témoigner du modèle de la mobilisation
absolument totale de tout le monde de
toute la filière naturellement tous les
salariés d'EDF et de l'ensemble des
partenaires qui nous aident sur ce
processus
naturellement nous continuons d'avoir
des réacteurs qui sont en réparation pas
forcément pour des questions de
corrosion sous contrainte nous avons des
réacteurs qui passent en visite
décennale une visite décennale nécessite
un arrêt de plusieurs mois et la
complexité de ces visites décennales
nécessite des durées allongées de
d'arrêt de réacteur donc nous continuer
de travailler sur l'accélération
l'ensemble de ces processus comme un
élément tout à fait clé de la
disponibilité du parc et d'autres
capacité à produire une entreprise à
vocation à produire donc c'est bien la
nôtre et c'est là-dessus que nous sommes
attendus et ça sera naturellement ça
continuera d'être ma priorité mais poser
une question sur Excel
donc j'ai appris ce qui était Excel plus
en détail depuis que je suis dans
l'entreprise j'ai trouvé un plan très
bien monté de professionnalisation
accélération de la conduite des projets
industrialisation des projets qui nous
aident à tirer toutes les leçons de
flamants ville 3 notamment dans la façon
dont nous abordons nos autres grands
chantiers nucléaires et
au passage il y a quelques semaines à
peine le patron du projet Excel a fait
un rapport public sur sur le déroulement
du plan et mon ambition est dans
n'étendre les compétences et la portée
au sein de l'entreprise pour atteindre
toutes les dimensions de l'entreprise
avec la même logique industrielle sur
les modalités de financement je vous
remercie de m'avoir reposé la question
et je m'excuse de ne pas avoir répondu
directement à la Présidente
il nous reste il nous reste du travail
voilà ce que je peux dire à ce stade
et pour dire les choses simplement
en tant en tant que chef d'entreprise
mon souhait est naturellement de faire
en sorte que la performance de
l'entreprise contribue dans la plus
large mesure possible au financement de
son futur et son futur est de continuer
à produire et donc de créer des
instruments qui permettent sa production
future notre performance a recoupler les
réacteurs actuels au réseau et produire
des gigawh des terres et naturellement
une condition indispensable pour
faciliter le financement du futur ce
n'est pas une condition suffisante
une partie de la condition des
conditions qui rendraient le financement
suffisant se trouve dans la régulation
j'avais eu l'occasion lors de mon
audition de qualifier je crois le
dispositif de la reine de aboutsouffle
je vous confirme qu'il l'est
et
nous sommes à ce stade dans une crise
énergétique européenne qui amène à
revoir l'ensemble des modalités de
règles de marché
pour l'électricité en Europe et je vous
confirme que cette cette révision est
également indispensable pour que EDF
puisse au fond faire son travail de
producteur et de fournisseurs
électriques amènent une électricité
compétitive aux Français mais dans des
conditions qui ne obligent pas EDF soit
à vendre à un prix cassé qui est fixé
par la régulation soit à vendre en étant
l'objet des fluctuations excessives du
marché et au passage on est en taxé
après parce que c'est fluctuations sont
excessives quand on l'ensemble de tout
cela on arrive à un modèle économique
pour EDF qui soutient à peine l'activité
d'aujourd'hui et qui évidemment n'a pas
la capacité de financer le futur donc
mon souhait est de travailler avec le
gouvernement qui est évidemment tout à
fait mobilisé sur ce sujet dans les
discussions communautaires pour trouver
un équilibre économique qui nous permet
pour EDF et pour toute la filière parce
que
ce que EDF réussira à faire Nevot que si
ça embarque l'économie de la filière que
nous puissions établir un plan qui donne
suffisamment de visibilité économique à
moyen terme pour embarquer ce qu'il est
nécessaire de faire pour que la
performance actuelle du réseau soit
améliorée bien sûr fait du réseau du
parc pardon soit amélioré et pour faire
en sorte que le futur puisse être très
largement là dans la plus grande mesure
possible financée par l'investissement
de l'entreprise et pour le reste
naturellement nous discuterons avec les
pouvoirs publics lorsqu'il s'agira de
donner une perspective financière de
plus long terme qui dépasse une capacité
d'entreprise
voilà ce que je peux dire sur les prix
sur vos questions monsieur rapporteur
Martin
sur le temps que l'on gagne je ne sais
pas
je préfère étonné je ne sais pas je
pense qu'il est significatif mais donc
je pense qu'il se compte en année mais
je ne sais pas vous donner un nombre de
mois ou un nombre d'années donc je vous
reviendrai bien volontiers avec une
réponse la plus précise possible sur ce
sujet
sur sur les périmètres engagés par les
projets
en fait sont des emprises qui sont déjà
extrêmement proches qui sont sur le site
vous les connaissez je pense puisque
voilà donc je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
formuler ici
et que ça brûle tout une une définition
technique de la distance je ne sais pas
si c'est possible mais en tout cas
physiquement on parle de sites qui qui
ont une capacité supplémentaire et pour
lesquelles il est il est tout à fait
possible de de gérer la croissance de
l'activité industrielle sur le site
voilà quand à la réalisation des
bâtiments ce que je vous confirme c'est
qu'il y a déjà beaucoup de travail fait
depuis plusieurs années dans la
définition même du projet EPR 2 pour
tirer toutes les leçons de Flamanville 3
et les leçons sont nombreuses à tirer et
c'est le son a été tiré en collaboration
avec la SN comme le disait le présent le
président de résoudre tout à l'heure
[Musique]
la construction de le PR2 de le père de
Flamanville pardon notamment sur la
notion d'exclusion de rupture donc nous
avons approfondu ce sujet et nous avons
pris une position qui aujourd'hui permet
d'avoir suffisamment de visibilité pour
poursuivre les études de conception
nous sommes encore en discussion pour
avec EDF pour finaliser les éléments qui
d'entrer dans ces études de conception
et j'ai récemment demandé à EDF toujours
dans le même esprit d'anticipation que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure de faire un
point complet des points qui sont encore
à arbitrer avec la SN pour pouvoir
finaliser ses études de conception
détaillées c'est un élément important
dans le respect du planning il faut
comme le rapport folk le mettait bien en
évidence il faut absolument achever ces
études de conception détaillées avant de
lancer les projets les projets pour ne
pas commettre comme comme pardon avoir
les mêmes difficultés
donc voilà c'est un sujet tout à fait
important sur lequel nous nous
travaillons et lorsque l'on regarde
finalement les évolutions qui seront
mises en oeuvre sur les le PR2 par
rapport à l'EPR de Flamanville avec
également l'intégration du retour
d'expérience de fonctionnement des
epères de taille Chan et de okloto on
peut considérer que la première paire de
réacteur sur Pandy sera une quasi-tête
de série il y a quand même à des écarts
donc il faut faire attention d'où
l'importance d'achever les études
détaillées de conception pour pouvoir
maîtriser les délais en termes de sûreté
le niveau atteint par le PR2 sera
équivalent à celui de Flamanville et
s'agissant d'un réacteur de 3e
génération il n'y aura pas d'évolution
significative en matière de production
de déchets ce sera exactement le même
type de de déchets correspondant à ce
type de réacteur
pour les SMS ou les Amr les réacteurs
petits réacteurs avancés la situation
pourrait être différente vu leur taille
effectivement ça a été signalé ces
réacteurs permettrait vraisemblablement
des progrès en matière de sûreté
la puissance résiduelle à évacuer en cas
d'accident étant plus faible on pourrait
tout à fait imaginer que ces réacteurs
soient munis de dispositifs passifs
permettant d'assurer le refroidissement
du réacteur en cas de situation
accidentelle sans avoir besoin de
recours à des sources d'alimentation
électrique pendant une durée suffisante
ou d'avoir recours à des capacités en
eau supplémentaires donc ça c'est un
avantage tout à fait significatif s'il
peut être bien évidemment être mis en
oeuvre par rapport au gros réacteur si
je peux prendre cette expression de type
EPR pour lesquels il faut assurer en
permanence même en situation d'arrêt à
des conditions refroidissement qui
nécessitent de l'alimentation électrique
pas de parallèle avec la situation en
Ukraine mais on voit bien que c'est
absolument indispensable même lorsque
les réacteurs sont à l'arrêt donc ça
c'est un élément tout à fait fondamental
de différence entre les SMR et les
réacteurs de type EPR alors les projets
avancent sur ce sujet en France et
aujourd'hui la SN est à ce stade en
relation avec quatre porteurs de projets
qui présentent chacun des projets de
technologie différents le projet le plus
avancé ça a été cité tout à l'heure
c'est celui de New World qui est porté
par EDF avec CEAT technique Atom et
naval group il s'agit d'un SMR sur une
technologie qui est maîtrisée c'est
celle des réacteurs à eau sous pression
nous avons dans notre parc actuel et qui
ne présenterait pas de différence en
matière de gestion de combustible et de
déchets
pour se prononcer sur ces options de
sûreté nous avons pris une initiative
qui est unique au mot puisque nous avons
en discussion avec EDF décider
d'associer les autorités de sûreté check
et finlandaise qui correspondait à deux
pays ciblés par EDF comme susceptible
d'être intéressé par ce projet pour
faire ensemble une prise de position sur
les options de sûreté du réacteur
new-ward et ça c'est très important
parce que ça donne une visibilité
internationale dès le début dans le
processus de décision en tout cas de
prise de position sur les options de
sûreté les autres réacteurs pour
lesquels aujourd'hui nous avons des
discussions avec les porteurs de projets
sont des réacteurs de technologie
différentes des réacteurs à eau sous
pression il y a un réacteur refroidit au
plomb un réacteur à sel fondu et un
réacteur haute température on peut dire
que c'est la maturité technologique de
ces projets est très différente de celle
du réacteur New World donc il est encore
des travaux d'in et de recherche
vraisemblablement ces projets arriveront
à maturité plus tardivement que le
projet New World en revanche il y a une
compétition internationale qui est rude
qui avec des compétiteurs puissants
américains chinois russe qui développe
une politique assez agressive qui à la
fois en termes de compétitivité prix
mais également en termes de puissance
géopolitique d'influence pour pouvoir
imposer leurs projets y compris en
Europe de l'Est la part des Américains
donc attention à ce que ce projet s'émer
New World n'arrive pas trop tard dans la
compétition internationale c'est un
point de vigilance
alors pour revenir maintenant à certains
sujets qui ont été évoqués tout à
l'heure et pour répondre à la question
des déchets j'ai dit que le réacteur new
Award n'aurait pas de différence par
rapport au réacteurs actuel en ce qui
concerne la gestion des déchets ça
pourrait être en revanche différent pour
des projets qui seraient des projets de
type et réacteurs réacteurs à neutrons
rapides qui peuvent être des projets
basés sur les technologies que nous
avions développées en France il y a
quelques années notamment refroidie au
sodium mais avec des projets dont un qui
dans deux d'ailleurs qui sont présentés
refroidis aux plomb ou à celle fondue
la maturité là encore est très
différente la maturité d'un projet basé
sur
des réacteurs refroidis au sodium
pourrait tenir compte bien sûr du retour
d'expérience de la France sur ce type de
réacteur il y a quelques années ce n'est
pas le cas pour les deux autres types il
y a encore beaucoup de travaux de
d'innovation à développer pour pouvoir y
arriver moi je voudrais attirer
l'attention sur trois points sur ce
sujet SMR dont certains ont été évoqués
tout à l'heure trois points de
préoccupation suivant la SN qui doivent
accompagner les le développement des
projets SMR donc tout d'abord il faut
effectivement porter une plus grande
attention au cycle du combustible dans
le foisonnement des projets qui sont
présentés il y a plus d'une centaine de
projets qui sont présentés sur les SMR
dans le monde il y en a très peu qui
portent attention aujourd'hui à la
question du cycle combustible on ne sait
pas d'où vient le combustible là parfois
pas d'usine pour pouvoir produire les
combust qui sont envisagés qui sont des
combustibles à densité plus importante
que celle que nous utilisons et il y a
pratiquement jamais le débat sur l'aval
du cycle qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
combustibles usés et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des déchets donc il faut bien avoir
une vision globale pour que ces projets
soient présentés de manière je dirais
sincère il s'agit pas uniquement du
réacteur il s'agit de tout ce qui
entoure le réacteur ça c'est le premier
point d'attention il faut absolument
avoir une vision intégrée de
développement des SMS et la France
possède peut-être d'ailleurs un avantage
sur le sujet puisqu'il est capable de
présenter le sujet globalement
puisqu'elle maîtrise les technologies le
deuxième sujet et qui est directement
lié au débat que nous avons eu tout à
l'heure sur la possibilité d'implanter
des réacteurs nucléaires notamment de
petites tailles en dehors des sites
nucléaires existants c'est la question
de la sécurité
différence entre sûreté nucléaire c'est
ce que ce dont s'occupe la SN en matière
de risque accidentel et la sécurité
nucléaire qui est la lutte contre les
actes de malveillance y compris les
attaques les attaques criminelles les
attaques attentats le risque de
cybersécurité là on est devant un sujet
qui bien évident est plus complexe pour
un petit réacteur qui serait implanté
dans une zone industrielle voire à
proximité d'une agglomération qu'un
réacteur qui sera implanté sur un gros
site nucléaire qui est déjà
sécurisé avec avec beaucoup de moyens y
compris des moyens d'intervention qui
permettent d'attendre l'arrivée des
forces de l'ordre lorsqu'il y a eu une
intrusion criminelle sur le site donc ce
sont des sujets qui sont imposés qu'ils
doivent être portés par les exploitants
des futurs SMR donc je dis attention
c'est un sujet qu'il ne faut pas perdre
de vue parce que autant il est tout à
fait tout à fait justifié de
s'interroger sur le développement des
usages de ces petits réacteurs pour
pouvoir faire de la chaleur de
l'hydrogène pour pouvoir
accompagner la décarbonation de
l'industrie et donc implanter ces
réacteurs ailleurs que dans des gros
sites nucléaires avec des usages
immédiats locaux sans transport mais
attention la sécurité peut devenir un
sujet plus lourd à traiter que celui de
la sûreté donc il faut vraiment intégrer
les deux composantes délai début avec la
recherche de sécurité passive de la même
manière qui a surté passive dont je
parlais tout à l'heure et le troisième
sujet qui peut prendre en compte c'est
celui de du niveau d'exigence lié au SMR
dans la compétition internationale sur
le développement des sms il y a beaucoup
de débats puisque sur quel est le niveau
de sûreté à fixer pour les SMS certains
sont estimes que le niveau de sûreté des
réacteurs de troisième génération doit
être le modèle pour les SMS d'autres
estiment et c'est le cas de la SN que il
faut retenir un niveau d'exigence qui
permette d'exploiter les potentialités
d'amélioration qui sont rendus possibles
par les SMR bien évidemment à un coût
économiquement acceptable si on peut
aller plus loin que le niveau de sûreté
des réacteurs de 3e régénération il faut
le faire il se devrait être la position
qui serait à tenir et il est absolument
important de notre point de vue que l'on
tienne compte du fait qu'il y a un tel
engouement autour des SMS que si tout
ceci se réalise il y a un nombre très
important de pays qui aujourd'hui n'ont
aucune expérience nucléaire qui ne sont
pas nucléarisées il y a 40 pays qui se
sont signalés à laua comme intéressé par
les SMS et qui n'ont aucune installation
nucléaire aujourd'hui donc il y a un
véritable risque de mettre en main de
pays qui n'ont pas d'autorité de surquet
qui n'ont pas d'expérience industrielle
des risques industriels des réacteurs
qui peuvent poser problème ne perdons
pas de vue que la confiance dans la
sûreté et l'engouement ou le
désengouement sur le nucléaire et
parfois lié à des événements qui se
produisent très de chez nous à partir
d'un accident et qui peuvent
complètement inverser l'option que l'on
peut avoir ou l'opinion qu'on peut avoir
sur le développement du nucléaire donc
s'il est possible d'avoir des réacteurs
petits qui soient plus sûr il faut pas
s'en priver je pense que ça fait partie
également d'une réponse au
préoccupations légitime de la population
bien évidemment il y a certains SMS qui
peuvent aller plus loin par rapport à la
question des déchets ce sont les
questions les SMR à neutrons rapides qui
permettraient comme la filière neutre
rapide en France d'envisager une
réduction des déchets voire
l'utilisation de matière de matière
nucléaire qui sont aujourd'hui sans
usage voilà en ce qui concerne les SMS
les réponses et de paires de réponses
que je voulais apporter à vos questions
en ce qui concerne maintenant les
risques liés à la construction de
nouveaux nucléaires les extensions de
sites donc là la gestion cumulée des
risques notamment des risques
d'agression des risques d'agression
naturel vous avez parlé de subversion
marine mais on peut aussi se poser la
question du réchauffement climatique il
y a aussi s'il y a plus de sites il y
aura peut-être des sites aussi en bord
de fleuves la question des de des
tornades des séismes tout ceci ce sont
des éléments d'agressions qui doivent
être prises en compte y compris sur des
durées de vie qui correspondent à la
durée de vie des projets donc là on a
des projets qui vont durer un siècle
jusqu'à la fin pratiquement au moment où
on les conçoit au moment où on les met à
l'arrêt et donc il faut intégrer cette
période de temps dans la démonstration
de sûreté sur la base des éléments qui
sont connus donc il y a bien évidemment
les prévisions du du GIEC mais on voit
bien que ces prévisions peut-être aussi
amenées à évoluer dans le temps et donc
c'est nous avons en France un exercice
que vous connaissez bien qui est celui
qui réexamen de sûreté tous les 10 ans
et donc tous les 10 ans nous faisons de
nouveau une évaluation des aléas qui
sont à prendre en compte pour pouvoir
ajuster le la sûreté des installations
par rapport à ce risque extérieur nous y
compris par rapport aux installations
industrielles voisines par exemple la
Gravelines lorsqu'on en a fait le
examencurité de Gravelines on a pris en
compte les évolutions du terminal gazier
qui était à proximité pour traiter cette
coactivité industrielle donc on voit
bien qu'on est dans un système où on est
capable de faire évoluer la sûreté des
installations en fonction de leur
évolution de l'évolution de leur
environnement bien évidemment par
rapport au risque de submersion marine
il y a eu là aussi à Gravelines comme à
blayer comme à Tricastin des
réhaussements de digue donc on peut se
protéger davantage lorsque les hélas
évoluent dernier sujet que je voudrais
aborder c'est finalement le sujet global
de de l'anticipation et de la gestion du
temps on a beaucoup parlé des projets se
verra à souligné d'autres l'ont fait
d'ailleurs le fait que
on a un parc nucléaire existant qui a
été construit à 75% dans les années 80
donc on a beaucoup de réacteurs qui vont
vivre à peu près en même temps et
lorsque l'on regarde
de projection sur un mix énergétique à
2050 et après 2050
et c'est la question aussi du nombre de
PA2 on voit bien que tous ces réacteurs
vont atteindre à peu près 70 ans 70 ans
c'est plus que la durée de vie pour
laquelle aujourd'hui nous nous sommes
prononcés pour les réacteurs actuels les
éléments qui nous ont été fournis par
EDF nous ont permis de nous positionner
jusqu'à 50 ans pas au-delà donc première
message que je veux faire passer c'est
que dans le débat certes il y a le débat
que vous avez qui est celui de des
projets de nouveaux nucléaires mais pas
dans le projet de loi que nous avons ici
mais plus tard dans le projet de loi de
l'année prochaine il faut absolument
s'interroger sur les mesures
d'accompagnement qui permettront de
donner de la visibilité et d'anticiper
l'échéance 2050 pour les réacteurs en
service il faut le faire avec beaucoup
de temps en avance donc je répète c'est
un message que j'avais déjà fait passer
il faut que dans les quelques années qui
viennent nous ayons un vrai analyse de
fond pour savoir quel peut être la durée
de vie du parc des réacteurs nucléaires
d'EDF et avec suffisamment
d'anticipation pour pouvoir ajuster les
résultats en tout cas les conséquences
qui peuvent être d'ailleurs des
conséquences attirer sur le nombre de
réacteurs à décider donc il faut lier
les deux on ne peut pas s'intéresser
uniquement sur les nouveaux réacteurs en
séparant la question des réacteurs
actuels sur leur durée de vie nous
n'avons pas ces justifications et moi je
ne souhaite pas en tant que président de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire que la
poursuite d'exploitation des réacteurs
nucléaires en France soit la variable
d'ajustement d'une politique énergétique
qui aurait été mal calibrée c'est
essentiel il faut lier les deux sujets
donc ça c'est le premier point et je
terminerai sur toujours en termes
d'anticipation je crois qu'il y a un
deuxième sujet qui est tout est de
déroulement des projets qui est tout à
fait fondamental c'est bien évidemment
celui des capacités industrielles à
faire depuis le début nous avons parlé
de de effectivement des projets de loi
mais de texte mais tout ça ne suffit pas
pour tenir le calendrier pour le tenir
le calendrier il y a effectivement la
capacité à faire et là je pense que il y
a vraiment deux enjeux fondamentaux pour
lesquels la filière c'est mobilisée on a
tout à fait conscience c'est tout
d'abord celui de renforcer
substantiellement l'attractivité de la
filière pour pouvoir recruter et
conserver les compétences et je dirais
dans tous les métiers dans tous les
métiers et à tous les niveaux du col
blanc ou col bleu aujourd'hui il y a un
déficit total dans tous les métiers par
rapport au prévision qui sont faites sur
ce qui est nécessaire donc ça c'est
quand bien même les textes le extrait si
les compétences ne sont pas là au moment
dans tous les métiers les projets ne
pourront pas se dérouler correctement et
là il y aura des pertes de temps
deuxième point c'est il faut bien
évidemment
reconstituer la capacité industrielle
donc ça c'est la perte de capacité
industrielle à faire à faire mais au bon
standard attendu dans le nucléaire et ce
standard attendu a parfois pas été
atteint dans les constructions récentes
et pour la SN la qualité et la rigueur
j'insiste beaucoup sur la rigueur à la
fois de la conception j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure le travail fait sur la
conception détaillée dans la fabrication
et dans le contrôle c'est la première
barrière de sûreté il faut vraiment la
traiter et
de manière approfondie pour ne pas avoir
de risque de déboire par la suite et à
en parallèle à ses compétences et à la
question fondamentale de la gestion et
du pilotage des projets suffit pas
d'avoir les compétences il faut savoir
les assembler embarquer la filière gérer
les projets de manière professionnelle
et ça c'est un sujet important parce
qu'il n'a pas été à la hauteur dans les
derniers projets précédents merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Monsieur
Jacques vous voulez rajouter des
éléments de réponse oui merci madame la
Présidente
la recherche avait été prise en compte
et de manière satisfaisante dans le
cadre de la loi je vais me permettre un
petit écart par rapport à ça et puis
revenir à cette question je voudrais
réinsister sur sur un point qui est
celui finalement de qu'est-ce que peut
apporter la recherche en termes de
cohérence des trajectoires c'est à dire
c'était ça a été développé par ton avis
tout à l'heure on a diverses
technologies elles sont pas en
compétition mais elles doivent être
articulées donc si on n'a pas une bonne
maîtrise de ce que sont les feuilles de
route des diverses technologies de ce
que sont leurs jalons de ce que sont les
points de rendez-vous ou si l'une n'est
pas disponible et si l'autre l'Est on va
avoir plus ou moins de difficultés on
aura clairement
du mal à bâtir à bâtir un mix solide ce
qui veut dire que là-dessus c'est bien
sur la recherche sur l'innovation pour
autant que ça puisse se prévoir mais en
tout cas au moins en anticipation de ce
que sont les feuilles de route
technologiques qu'on doit œuvrer bon
donc ça c'est sur la recherche au global
la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
c'est
il m'ennuie parfois c'est que la
recherche est considérée comme une comme
une commodité c'est à dire que je vais
pas répéter ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire c'est tenu pour
acquis je pense que ce n'est pas le cas
et qu'il faut vraiment malgré et je
voudrais y rendre hommage toute la
mobilisation
et le caractère souvent exceptionnel je
le dis j'y suis pour rien des équipes du
CEA
dans le domaine du nucléaire et pas que
qui se sont mobilisés parfois avec des
vents mauvais et des situations où on
peut pas dire que c'était toujours
en haut en haut en haut des priorités
ils ont maintenu haut le niveau de
compétence parce qu'on parlait de
compétences tout à l'heure je pense que
nous avons une compétence en matière de
recherche qui est reconnue au niveau
mondial au niveau mondial j'avais
plaisir d'être aux États-Unis il y a pas
très longtemps et de rencontrer mon
homologue du dioi d'une vie partante de
l'énergie si le dioi prend le temps de
discuter avec le CEA et de considérer
que le CEA est un alter ego c'est bien
parce que la compétence est là
maintenant il faut être il faut être
vigilant par rapport à ça je veux
vraiment y insister l'extrême
mobilisation des personnels il suffira
pas toujours alors du coup le projet de
loi ne prend pas vraiment en compte la
recherche mais il a pas à la prendre en
compte d'une certaine façon le projet de
loi il a une vocation d'accélération de
projets industriels je crois que c'est
c'est bien ça qui qui doit être le cas
et il a pas vocation à apporter des
solutions immédiates sur sur la
recherche en revanche le fait de pour
les aider à ultérieures
le bien garder en tête ce que la manière
dont le continuum entre la recherche et
l'exploitation finalement de la
recherche à l'exploitation des outils du
parc leur conception leur exploitation
ça il faut absolument le garder et
garder en tête et puis j'en viens à la
question que posait monsieur le
rapporteur sur les SMMA alors le
président de l'Autorité a dit tout ce
qu'il fallait dire sur les SMS y compris
des choses qui relevaient semble-t-il de
la recherche aussi mais peu importe moi
je je pense que alors faut qu'on
s'entende les SMS ne sont pas la panacée
universelle
et quiconque c'est exactement comment ça
va se passer quels vont être les modèles
économiques comment ça va comment ça va
déboucher est extrêmement fort ceci dit
j'ai toujours dit je persiste à dire
depuis 2018 que c'est une voix qui se
regarde qui s'explore qui se considère
avec attention quand je racontais ça en
2018 je faisais sourire maintenant
finalement bon nul des prophètes dans
son pays nul n'est prophètes oui
maintenant je suis trop timide nul n'est
prophètes dans son pays bon à partir de
là je pense qu'il faut effectivement en
voir tous les aspects je partage ce que
dit le le président de russe sur les
questions de sécurité parce
qu'effectivement un des intérêts de ces
réacteurs sont sont de faire de la
sûreté passive aussi mais je pense qu'il
faudra être raisonnable c'est-à-dire
qu'il faudra voilà avoir une
proportionnalité aux enjeux pour voir si
effectivement il y a une place pour ces
pour ces pour ces instruments là mais il
est clair que si on leur applique des
cadres qui ne sont pas adaptés à leur
nature et qu'on met toutes les
contraintes au maximum sur ces
instruments ça c'est sûr on n'arrivera
pas à les développer ça ça je pense
qu'il faut il faut il faut il faut
absolument que là-dessus alors après sur
la question de à quoi ils peuvent servir
soyons clairs il y a effectivement des
choses qui sont avec les petits
réacteurs
qui vont être bien utile aussi dans le
bilan bien utile aussi probablement par
rapport à des questions de structure du
réseau et effectivement si on prend le
cas de l'hydrogène et on pourrait en
imaginer d'autres dès lors que vous avez
un petit réacteur que ce petit réacteur
il est capable de fournir un peu de
chaleur un peu d'électricité que vous
pouvez le coupler en mode permanent et
continu avec par exemple une
installation d'électrolyse haute
température vous allez avoir quelque
chose qui va être de mon point de vue
plus simple à gérer en termes de
d'équilibre d'équilibre global après ils
ne font pas que ça ça c'est pour les
plus classiques ils peuvent faire
effectivement des choses alors avec des
usages de chaleur beaucoup plus
importants parce que je pense que si on
regarde cette fois-ci les réacteurs
avancés enfin ce qu'on appelle advance
finalement ils ont deux vocations
principales une qui va être sur le cycle
une qui va être le recyclage de la
matière je reviendrai sur la question
des déchets après qui me tient à cœur
aussi mais
et donc évidemment si on n'a pas le
cycle pensez à côté ces réacteurs
perdent un peu de leur intérêt parce
qu'ils risquent d'être plus cher
potentiellement euh parce qu'ils auront
des cycles compliqués sans sans traiter
le problème de la matière donc ça ça
serait difficile mais ils peuvent aussi
être des fournisseurs de de chaleur à
très haute température qui ne sortiront
pas d'un rept typiquement et et donc ça
c'est c'est un point qui qui faut
considérer sur la question des déchets
je suis toujours d'une extrême prudence
c'est-à-dire que je me méfie par
procession de pas du passé de toutes les
démarches zéro déchets le zéro déchet ça
n'existe pas le zéro déchet ça n'existe
pas et on peut se raconter tout ce qu'on
veut sur les sites nucléaires quand vous
faites des réactions de fission il y
aura des produits de fission bon et les
produits de fission sont constitutifs
d'une bonne part de la dose à l'exutoire
d'un stockage comme chacun sait donc de
toute façon ça ça et je pense que si on
ne dit pas ça on va avoir des gros
problèmes avec le public et donc pardon
c'est l'ancien responsable de certaines
trucs qui dit ça mais je me sens
toujours un devoir de solidarité avec
mes mes collègues mes collègues
d'autrefois voilà donc pour pour pour
conclure moi je sur ce point mais
Monsieur le porteur je pense que la
recherche est complètement solidaire de
la démarche qui est c'est à dire elle
est elle est en appui elle est en
soutien elle n'est pas celle qui va être
directement visé par le projet de loi
mais toutes les questions posées le
président de relook sur qu'est-ce que
serait le cadre de bon développement des
petits réacteurs etc sera peut-être un
sujet sur lequel on aura l'occasion de
revenir vous voir parce que je pense que
ça ça se posera d'une manière ou d'une
voilà merci madame la Présidente merci
beaucoup monsieur duroff monsieur le
président
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez posé
une question sur le vieillissement et la
pérennisation possible de de l'outil
industriel notamment de la fin de cycle
donc les usines de lag et le Médoc qui
arrivent alors 50e année de
fonctionnement comme vous l'avez rappelé
en 2040
alors je me permettrai de rappeler pour
tous que la PPE
2019-2028 qui est celle actuellement en
vigueur effectivement confirmer la
stratégie française de traitement
recyclage jusqu'à cette horizon 2040
mais à laisser la question ouverte pour
la suite donc la prochaine Pepe doit y
répondre
et donc pour pouvoir y répondre
soit finalement on décide d'aller vers
une ouverture de cycle et donc quelque
part de l'entreposage soit ceux qui
sembleraient souhaitable et j'avais
rappelé dans dans ma réponse à madame la
Présidente la forte avance technologique
française dans la matière
réaffirmer la stratégie de traitement
recyclage au-delà de 2040 mais si on va
dans cette direction là et compte tenu
du temps industriel à la fois de
conception et de construction il est
bien évidemment nécessaire de prendre
des décisions bien en amont et pour être
très direct et pour être très clair et
d'ailleurs
nombre de personnes autour de cette
table a commencé par le président de
rosuques l'ont appelé ces décisions
doivent être prises dans le courant du
quinquennat actuel et de préférence en
2025 je rappelle juste aussi parce
qu'au-delà des compétences on sait tous
que il y a les compétences il y a aussi
l'expérience
nous sommes dans la dernière décennie on
pourra bénéficier du retour d'expérience
de ceux qui ont construit ces usines
et c'est quelque chose à ne pas à ne pas
omettre à ne pas oublier
dernier point en mettant juste mon grain
de sel dans dans la discussion sur les
SMR mais surtout sur les Amr faut pas
oublier que c'est ces types de réacteurs
ont besoin de combustible ces réacteurs
en général ont tendance à oublier que
quand on enfin tendance plutôt à penser
que quand on a conçu le réacteur c'est
très facile de mettre du combustible
dedans pour le faire démarrer mais c'est
réacteurs notamment sur une nouvelle
génération besoin en général de
combustible un peu spécifique qui fait
appel aux usages de traitement et de
recyclage très clairement ils ont besoin
de plutonium et donc pour se faire et
pour pouvoir démarrer ce type de
réacteur qui présente d'autres qualités
qui ont été rappelées et ben il est
évident qu'il faut aussi penser l'outil
industriel qui va avec et donc c'est une
raison supplémentaire pour se poser la
question de savoir qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire des usines actuelles comment
est-ce qu'on est prolonge comment est-ce
qu'on est pérennise éventuellement
comment est-ce qu'on est renouvelle
bien Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur
verenque oui merci merci madame la
Présidente déjà je vais rassurer
François Jacques parce que quand il a
parlé de SMR en 2018 c'était pas
complètement tombé dans l'oreille d'un
sourd puisqu'on en a mis dans certains
de nos scénarios et c'est grâce au CEA
voilà mais c'est vrai que quand on a
commencé ça mais même c'est un scénario
à 14 pères en 2018 2019 ça n'était pas
mainstream permettez-moi de cette
anglicisme
Bernardo qui a parlé d'anticipation moi
je veux revenir là-dessus parce que
c'est absolument central c'est ça qui
nous a animé pour les deux ans nos
scénario c'est faire émerger des rétros
planning
pour intégrer l'effet falaise pour
intégrer la question du renouvellement
des infrastructures de de retraitement
recyclage pour éviter justement qu'on
ait des variables d'ajustement subies
après des scénarios justement sont pas
des outils pour ce sont des outils pour
se représenter le monde ils sont pas
figés on va en réalité pas suivre
mécaniquement un scénario
dans les prochaines années la fin de
notre rapport de de 202122 elle est
consacrée aux incertitudes et on se dit
en réalité la courbe de consommation
d'électricité elle s'infléchira à un
moment à la hausse mais on sait pas
exactement quand est-ce que ça va être
en 2023 en 26 il y a de l'incertitude
l'accélération des renouvelables entre
le dire et le voir sur le terrain il y a
quand même un écart
la production du parc nucléaire actuel
poste grand carénage et post corrosion
sous contrainte il y a de l'incertitude
en matière de volume on l'a bien vu
cette année
l'hydrogène bon voilà je pourrais citer
toutes les incertitudes ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'on ait une stratégie
énergétique qui nous permette de gérer
des écarts par rapport aux hypothèses et
donc avec un peu de jeu le problème
c'est que ça serait ça serait d'arriver
une situation où il y a plus de jeu du
tout et là on aura donc des variables
d'ajustement subies et je voudrais juste
sur cette question anticipation ne qu'on
oublie pas la question du réseau
et notamment la question de la
planification géographique ce sera pas
la même chose de mettre des EPR sur des
sites existants par exemple pas pour pas
en livre ce qu'on lit c'est la question
est très claire mais sur Gravelines
selon la date de fermeture des réacteurs
actuels c'est peut-être pas exactement
le même réseau qu'il faut dans cette
zone là donc voilà et ça c'est des
décisions y compris sur le notre réseau
national elle se prennent très très
longtemps auparavant alors je suis quand
même répondre à la question monsieur le
rapporteur sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement sinon vous seriez
déçu
alors le peut-être juste dire les
inquiétudes telles qu'elles sont
retranscrit médiatiquement porte
beaucoup sur les volumes d'électricité
quand on a publié nos analyses on a
essayé de dire que l'aspect économique
l'aspect prix était au moins aussi
important parce qu'en réalité pour
l'instant il y a jamais eu de problème
de volume on est on est dans une
situation tendue on l'a dit mais mais il
y a pas de en revanche
les conséquences de cette crise sur les
prix et elles sont elles sont déjà là et
elles sont
elles créent une tension avec notre
agenda de de réindustrialisation
d'électrification donc ça c'est une
problématique très structurante et après
pourquoi pour cet hiver rappeler qu'en
fait on a trois crises imbriquées d'une
dans l'autre on a une crise durablement
de l'approvisionnement en gaz qui est là
pour plusieurs années donc moi je mets
cet hiver dans un contexte plus général
une question de production nucléaire qui
est liée essentiellement à la corrosion
sous contrainte cette année mais dans un
système qui était déjà très tendu et une
crise de production hydraulique au cours
de cette année l'hydraulique c'est notre
deuxième source de production
d'électricité alors c'est vrai en France
c'est vrai aussi dans un certain nombre
d'entrepris il faut pas l'oublier parce
que ça a conduit à des situations de
tension qui sont qui sont réelles vous
n'oubliez pas mais souvent on parle
toujours de nucléaire et jamais
d'hydraulique les droïques c'est un
deuxième source c'est une énergie
renouvelable c'est un énorme potentiel
le flexibilité et donc nous pensons à
elle bon
quand on a publié l'analyse globale sur
cet hiver c'était en septembre il y
avait trois grands scénarios ce qu'on
peut dire déjà aujourd'hui c'est que
nous avons écarté le scénario le plus
contraint celui du bas le scénario le
scénario du pire pourquoi quand on
regarde les grands les grandes
les grands paramètres la consommation
d'électricité on publie toutes les
semaines une évaluation de la
consommation tous les mardis soirs qui
est retraités des des aléas
météorologiques donc c'est pas la
consommation brute et la consommation
retravaillée ramener à une température
normale au niveau de la France entière
sur les quatre dernières semaines elle
est en diminution de 9% et sur la
dernière semaine
9,7 donc c'est c'est tout à fait
considérable par rapport à la moyenne
2014 2019
et c'est pas uniquement un effet dans le
secteur de l'industrie c'est l'industrie
le tertiaire et le résidentiel donc là
aujourd'hui on a on a cette vision
complète c'est c'est très impressionnant
et honnêtement ce n'était absolument pas
gagné vu du mois de septembre donc il y
a quelque chose qui s'est passé pendant
le secteur industriel il y a une
question d'activité économique et de
signal prime et il y a aussi beaucoup
d'effets de sobriété qui sont désormais
visibles ça n'est plus du disco ça n'est
pas de la chimère voilà ça l'effet il
est très net et vu les températures
qu'on a qu'on a connues au cours des
derniers jours si on n'avait pas eu
cette baisse de la consommation la
situation aurait été tout autre
sur le nucléaire on est revenu sur notre
courbe de septembre de prévisions de
septembre moi je vous rappelle qu'on
avait
la situation je dirais je veux pas dire
confortable mais qui souhaitable pour
passer l'hiver c'était 40 gigawatts au
premier décembre et 45 début janvier
là on a le président Raymond là on a
parlé plus de 41 gigawatts de
disponibilité du parc nucléaire une
production du parc nucléaire donc on est
même légèrement au dessus de la courbe
bon c'est c'est très en dessous des
minimums mais vu la situation dans
laquelle on était c'est très
satisfaisant moi je remercie tous les
gens qui se sont mobilisés pour les
activités de maintenance
de et qui ont fait en sorte qu'on arrive
à ce niveau là parce que
on est dans une situation aujourd'hui il
y a une stratégie de le défaut identifié
on sait monsieur deauduc en parlerait
mieux que moi mais on sait quelles sont
les réacteurs qui sont qui sont
susceptibles d'être concernés
il y a eu des protocoles qui ont été
mises en œuvre je trouve qu'il y a
beaucoup moins d'incertitudes que
lorsque que au printemps et elle était
et donc moi je trouve que la situation
est bien plus favorable donc
[Musique]
on est on a vraiment et on est vraiment
pas du tout dans le bas du faisceau qui
pouvait être qui pouvait être craint au
début du mois de septembre sur
l'hydraulique alors là on a remonté on
est on était on est sorti des thés avec
un niveau de stock hydraulique
catastrophique et la gestion prudente
qu'on a eu au cours de cette période là
fait qu'aujourd'hui les stocks sont
revenus dans la dans les moyennes
historiques et que on a bien vu ces
derniers jours que on les pouvait les
utiliser donc ça c'est très satisfaisant
et puis un dernier point qui fonctionne
très bien ce sont les interconnexions
européennes alors là c'est extrêmement
fluide et et plus je dirais que souvent
il y a des gens nous ont posé la
question mais alors est-ce que les
autres pays vont nous envoyer de
l'électricité déjà je rappelle que en
fait ce sont pas les pays qui
s'échangent de l'électricité
ce sont ce sont les fournisseurs les
producteurs qui s'échangent qui qui
s'achètent de l'électricité les uns les
autres lundi
dernier donc il y a deux jours du froid
on était en train d'exporter vers le
Royaume-Uni le Royaume-Uni était dans
une situation physique économique qui
nécessitait plus d'électricité que la
France le système a objectivement
extrêmement bien fonctionné au cours de
manière très fluide on avait pris des
prudence par rapport aux interconnexions
on en prend toujours ça fonctionne
au-delà des prudence qu'on a prise pour
le moment et donc ça fait que la France
peut s'appuyer sur ce système voilà donc
une fois qu'on dit tout ça on est dans
une situation qui reste une situation de
grande vigilance on va on l'a dit et on
va pas le on va pas sortir de cette
situation là pour autant
une période qui était très risquée était
la fin du mois de novembre on l'avait
dit pourquoi à la fin du mois de
novembre parce que c'était le moment où
l'écart finalement ta disponibilité
nucléaire et
réel projeté la disponibilité x le
nucléaire historique était vraiment très
important cette période est derrière
nous il reste le janvier sur lequel on a
dit qu'on avait une vigilance
particulière mais c'est le cas tous les
ans chaque année c'est toujours le mois
de janvier qu'on regarde de manière de
manière prédominante et en matière de
risque je tiens quand même à dire que
nous avons certainement les moyens
d'éviter des coupures si jamais on
continue avec les taux actuels
d'économie d'énergie qui sont qui sont
qui sont constatés et qui sont
réellement qui sont réellement tout à
fait significatifs en quelques mois et
s'il y a des Mobilis de mobilisation
particulière lors des signaux hétéwatts
lorsqu'on a développé ce dispositif ça
n'est pas pour dire que il y aura
forcément une coupure c'est pour dire
que si jamais il y a une réaction
particulière lors de ces signaux
notamment des signaux rouges et bien
nous avons la faculté d'éviter les
délaissage et ça reste aujourd'hui notre
message on a l'impression que les
derniers jours nous ont montré que la
réaction des Français était
particulièrement à la hauteur de cette
situation
et bien merci beaucoup à tous je vais
maintenant passer la parole à mes
collègues et qui je vais demander
évidemment de la concision s'il vous
plaît de ne pas reposer des questions
qui leur est déjà été mais bien sûr dans
leur liberté de parole je vais commencer
par Franck montoget ensuite Jean-Claude
Tissot merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur pour vous présentation monsieur
de rosuk a dit qu'il ne souhaitait pas
je partage ce point de vue que le parc
actuel constitue la variable
d'ajustement de la production électrique
française je pense que c'est un problème
fondamental derrière ce propos moi je
comprends qu'il y a un risque que
notamment les six EPR 2 projetés ne
puissent pas être mis en service aux
dates indiquées 2035 2037 si si j'ai
bien compris donc voilà je voudrais
savoir dans une situation comme celle-là
effectivement où est la variable
ajustement et comment fait-on
monsieur Monsieur Raymond président de
DF quel est le montage financier
monsieur le Président
concernant les six EPR
voir les 8 est-ce que vous créez des
sociétés adoc de projet vous les ouvrez
vous ouvrez leur capital à qui au privé
comment quand le législateur selon vous
a-t-il doit-il avoir une place dans
cette dans cette question là
personnellement je pense je pense que
oui vous avez évoqué la révision des
règles de marché pour vous quelle
réforme de marché
européenne serait nécessaire pour que
EDF retrouve un modèle économique et
financier équilibré sur le long terme
comme ce fut le cas par le passé sur la
question du cycle
j'ai compris que si géo avait été fait
pour le parc actuel auquel on rajoute
flamainville donc ne serait pas
forcément disponible en l'état actuel de
sa conception en tout cas pour
le futur les futurs EPR cette question
a-t-elle été anticipée si oui par qui et
vers quoi se dirige-t-on en la matière
et sur la question du risque
géopolitique qui touche la main Lamont
du cycle quelles sont les orientations
géopolitiques de couverture des risques
identifiés voilà indépendamment du
risque que que j'ai appris à vous
écoutant monsieur de rosuk qui est celui
alors je l'appelle comme ça vous avez
pas employé le terme de proliférer de
prolifération des SMR voilà donc ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la question du risque
géopolitique sur l'approvisionnement en
uranium qui évidemment pour nous et une
question essentielle merci de
souveraineté de souveraineté
pour revenir un travail que nous avons
gagné Jean-Claude
ensuite Jean-Jacques Michaud merci en
fait
merci madame le Président Monsieur Merci
pour vos présentations certes longues
mais mais enrichissant
ces tableaux rondes et bien sûr la
première étape des travaux que nous
mènerons au Sénat sur le projet de loi
relatif à la construction des nouvelles
installations nucléaires et au
fonctionnement des installations
existantes mais avant de parler du
développement du nucléaire proprement
dit et aussi de lever les différentes
barrières administratives avec ce projet
de loi d'urgence comme ce fut le cas
pour le projet de loi de développement
des énergies renouvelables il me semble
important de ne pas totalement délaisser
les problématiques actuelles rencontrés
par la filière et je suis très heureux
de vous avoir entendu finalement tous un
monsieur Jacques Raymond
vous avez souligné l'intérêt de la
filière et et moi je vais poser une
question très précise que je pose assez
de façon régulière mais comme ce matin
pour moi à une connexion un peu
particulière parce que je vous ai
vraiment sous la main et et et et je
vais m'adresser à vous plus
particulièrement
sous la main apporter de d'échanges on
va dire
non non les gens je verbal
oui vous avez parlé de cycles vous avez
parlé et je reprendrai vos mots Monsieur
Jacques vous avez dit clairement les
déchets sont inévitables et moi je vais
je vais parler de l'amant
d'une mine d'uranium sur mon territoire
dans mon département il y a une mine qui
a été la mine de s'imprimer la prune qui
a été exploité pendant des dizaines
d'années c'est une problématique qu'on
connaît depuis 30 ans et je vous avais
il me semble vous étiez déjà là Monsieur
du rouge je crois que c'est vous que
j'avais sollicité ou pour vous
prédécesseur peut-être à ce sujet là et
et c'est vrai que ce site l'ensemble des
déchets radioactifs sont recouverts
d'une lame d'eau c'est le choix qui
avait été fait à l'époque pour pour
pérenniser ce site là et aujourd'hui
malheureusement on l'avait déjà dit
cette protection atteint ses limites et
durant l'été ce que nous préconise enfin
ce que nous craignons est arrivé et ça
d'ailleurs été constaté par Olivier
Masset qui est chargé de l'après-midi
chez Orano qui nous qui nous a dit très
clairement ce qui vient d'arriver
n'aurait pas dû avoir lieu mais on a été
rassuré parce que rapidement après il
nous a dit on est resté dans le cadre
réglementaire simplement en deux mots
l'eau est passé par dessus la digue
l'eau polluée
et bien évidemment la station de
traitement que vous avez mis en place
d'ailleurs il y a très peu de temps qui
quasiment neuve et ben après été du coup
était efficace donc ma question est très
claire monsieur le Président c'est
comment imaginez-vous
[Musique]
imaginez-vous l'aménagement du coup de
ce site pour la prémine aujourd'hui les
la les solutions que vous avez proposé
semble un peu courte
on demande depuis longtemps ouais je
suis désolé mais on demande depuis
longtemps une étude hydrogéologique sur
ce site et on l'attend toujours pour que
on puisse on puisse avoir une vision
fine de de de cet aspect là voilà donc
je suis ma question est précise
peut-être un peu moins généralistes que
mes collègues mais vous êtes ici dans la
chambre des territoires et on se doit
d'être le porte-parole de nos
territoires merci merci Jean-Claude
Michaud ensuite Serge Mériot
de vous remercier pour tout pour tous
ces apports ma question sera aussi
extrêmement précise à Monsieur le PDG
d'EDF si j'ai bien compris ce que vous
avez dit au début de l'année 2023 il
restera une dizaine de réacteurs à
l'arrêt donc je voudrais savoir combien
sont à l'arrêt dans le cadre de
l'entretien normal de grand carénage
autre et qu'elle combien sont par
rapport aux problèmes de corrosion sous
contrainte et donc plus globalement
comment dans les six 14 réacteurs à
venir on pourra éviter d'avoir ces
problèmes de corrosion sous contrôle
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
Jean-Jacques Serge Mériot ensuite Daniel
salmon oui madame la Présidente
messieurs ma question s'adresse
particulièrement à monsieur le Président
Directeur Général DDF
EDF c'est prêt à mon avis à juste titre
pendant cette dernière décennie de
manquer de cap sur
la volonté du gouvernement matière
d'énergie nucléaire est-ce que vous
considérez que la création des des six
réacteurs
et contradictoires avec le maintien le
maintien de l'arrêt de certains
rédacteurs de réacteurs
comment vous analysez ce double signal
qui peut apparaître contradictoire ça
c'est ma première question et qui à mon
avis lié d'ailleurs à la mobilisation de
la ressource humaine parce que s'il y a
pas de d'avenir dans la filière on a
probablement du mal à mobiliser des
jeunes et puis une remarque qui n'a pas
été abordée c'est peut-être hors sujet
ça concerne la fusion nucléaire j'ai vu
qu'il y avait eu un certain nombre de
résultats
très intéressant ces derniers jours
est-ce que c'est alors je sais que c'est
pas pour les 5 10 ans mais c'est quelque
chose qui m'intéresse est-ce que vous
pourriez nous en dire plus ce que ça
donne
quelques ouvertures ou pas et le dernier
point concernant la sobriété je crains
que le prix de l'énergie de l'énergie
électrique dans l'année 2023 créer une
sobriété subie parce que je crains que
c'est un impact terrible sur
l'agriculture sur l'artisanat et sur
l'industrie voilà alors là aussi je
voudrais éventuellement avoir votre
sentiment sur ce point-là et je vous
remercie merci beaucoup Serge ta
question me fait penser peut-être qu'on
peut en ce moment penser à Bernard Bigot
voilà qui avait fait une audition
remarquée ici et qui nous avait présenté
ITER voilà pour lequel on a une pensée
Daniel salmon ensuite amelgaquer
merci madame la Présidente merci
messieurs pour votre présentation je
viendrai simplement sur la question de
la crédibilité la sincérité de cette
programmation
on sait que vous appuyez sur un certain
nombre d'études mais j'aimerais bien que
vous nous en parliez pour nous expliquer
comment vous comptez atteindre
vos objectifs en termes de calendrier et
de coûts puisque l'on voit que le gap
est immense par rapport à la vitrine que
devait être le nucléaire français avec
le père de Flamanville
c'est des évolutions qu'on n'a jamais
constaté dans la filière industrielle
nucléaire c'est-à-dire avec des coûts
qui chutent de 120 euros le
mégawattheure à 75 et calendriers des
termes d'apprentissage qui sont très
très ambitieux donc est-ce que vous ne
pêchez pas par excès d'optimisme et
sinon deux questions on va dire plus
techniques nous savons que sur le Pr de
Tashan sur les cuves posent problème
avec des problèmes d'hydrauliques est-ce
que cette question là est réglée et
est-ce que ce seront les mêmes
typologies de cuve qui seront sur sur
l'EPR 2 d'ailleurs je suis bien noté que
Monsieur
neurosuc disait qu'on était là plutôt
sur une tête sur un prototype on était
sur une tête de série donc voilà ça
c'est à prendre en compte aussi dans le
calendrier et sinon plutôt sur le la
filière on va dire aval qu'en est-il des
saturations des piscines de la Hague
avec une échéance de 2030 qui est risque
de poser de sérieuses questions de
gestion des combustible d'usé merci
je vais être obligé de m'absenter donc
je regarderai les réponses très bien
Daniel Amel gaker ensuite Fabien gay
madame la Présidente messieurs nous sur
la relance de la filière nucléaire ont
déjà été évoquées les questions
essentielles de la disponibilité des
compétences du coup je m'arrêterai quand
même une petite minute sur ce dernier
point un coup de 3,3 milliards à 13
milliards pour le projet de Flamanville
interroge évidemment la production en
série pour les 6 EPS annoncé souvent
évoqué pour assurer sur un coup à
l'avenir davantage maîtrisé on parle
notamment de 50 milliards pour trois
nouvelles paires de réacteurs dans ce
cadre quels sont les modalités exactes
de financement quel impact pour EDF il
est en effet impensable de parler de
relance nucléaires sans évoquer les
questions de déchets et de démantèlement
d'installation actuelle sur les déchets
vous avez d'ores et déjà répondu je
pense quand même qu'un réel travail à
réel effort de pédagogie de transparence
est nécessaire pour rassurer nos
concitoyens pour qui parallèlement
risque d'accident la gestion en fait des
déchets reste un des sujets qui les pré
le plus et enfin concernant le
démantèlement il s'agit d'une vraie
question évidemment compte tenu du
vieillissement de notre parc nucléaire
neuf réacteurs sont en cours de
démantèlement selon EDF
a été évoqué un coup de 400 millions de
réacteurs le confirmez-vous et surtout
concrètement quelle plante de
déconstruction est envisagée à quel
échéance je vous remercie merci beaucoup
Amel pour ces questions précises Fabien
gay ensuite Sylviane Noël oui merci
madame le Président bonjour monsieur
aucune réflexion trois questions
précises puisque nous sommes pressés
la première c'est comme sur les énergies
renouvelables une fois qu'on a voté on a
du mal à voir avec quelle filière
industrielle on va développer les choses
et quel métier je vous remercie monsieur
Durot d'avoir évoqué sur les métiers
mais on sait que la filière nucléaire a
été peu attractive puisque il n'y avait
aucun projet on va revenir sur toutes
les tous les aléas politiques qui ont
connu à cette situation mais aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans cette situation et si
donc nous voulons recruter former ça va
prendre du temps et je le pose aussi à
Monsieur Raymond de DF je discute
régulièrement mais des syndicalistes il
me disent
AEDF on a des compétences mais on a
aussi du mal à la mise en oeuvre il n'y
a pas que chez les sous-traitants et ils
utilisent ils disent on est un gros
bateau il y a beaucoup de barreurs mais
peu de rameurs donc il va falloir il y a
beaucoup de métiers à recruter il y a
pas que les soudeurs où il y a des
difficultés il y a beaucoup de métiers
même y compris
j'ai envie de dire chez les ingénieurs
donc si on veut redonner concrètement
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire et j'entends
beaucoup parler d'université des du
nucléaire mais ça c'est pour l'instant
beaucoup hors-sol or mur avec des
formations maison on est loin quand même
des écoles de métiers donc il va falloir
une vraie formation et un vrai plan pour
mettre en oeuvre ce qu'on va décider
deuxième question je fais très vite
c'est la question la madame la Président
je le répète on a programmé des
fermetures est-ce qu'il y a pas quand
même un problème où on est encore sur la
fermeture de 12 à 14 réacteurs et
aujourd'hui se dire qu'on se lance dans
le nouveau nucléaire est-ce que pour
vous sur le projet de loi que nous
allons avoir en débat il faut revenir
sur ces fermetures c'est une question et
la dernière chose ça fait deux trois
fois qu'on ouvre la peau mais j'en
repose qui va payer
ah non mais là il faut qu'on sache il
faut qu'on sache avant le débat et
l'ouverture du débat le 17 janvier
est-ce que c'est EDF 100% une partie
privée quel montage financier précis
voyez et vous voyez bien la question à
laquelle je vais revenir ça peut pas
être DF qui va tout payer et une fois
qu'on aura tout monté dans 15 ans encore
à être dans l'arène 2.0 ou 3.0 ou eDF va
une nouvelle fois de voir vendre quel
que soit la réforme qui aura
aux acteurs privés
les bijoux quoi non mais je dis ça parce
que si
sur les nouveaux ah non mais attendez
surtout dans la situation dans laquelle
on vit alors je sais j'étais hyper
minoritaire il y a trois ans maintenant
tout le monde dit ceci je m'en réjouis
on va continuer l'activité personnelle
bref tant mieux mais il faut réformer ça
oui oui oui il faut abolir tout ça j'ai
bien une vision sur le marché européen
on aura l'occasion d'en discuter au mois
de janvier bref je m'arrête là mais il
faut qu'on ait les réponses précises sur
cette question là et il faudra que ça
soit dans le projet de loi parce qu'il
faut pas qu'on vote aujourd'hui et qu'on
nous dise dans quels ont ah oui on a
encore fait une erreur on n'avait pas
prévu le truc bon mais là comment se
pose les questions prévoyons tout ça dès
maintenant
très bien Fabien connaît ton engagement
Sylviane Noël ensuite Anne Catherine
Loisier merci madame la Présidente merci
à vous messieurs pour vos propos très
précis et on mesure à travers votre
exposé le travail colossal qui vous
attend pour tenter de sortir notre prix
notre pays de la grave crise énergétique
que nous rencontrons après une série de
renoncements très emblématique du
passage d'un état stratège à un état
très bavard et impotant j'avais une
question concernant les élèves où vous
nous parlez de 2035 sur la mise en
oeuvre de ces nouveaux réacteurs
je suis assez inquiète dans cette
intervalle comment
remplir nos besoins énergétiques qui ne
vont faire que croître malheureusement
durant cette période est-ce qu'on va
devoir vivre avec des périodes de
délestage et s'y habituer et des coûts
d'électricité difficilement supportable
et enfin pouvez-vous nous expliquer là
je sors un petit peu du nucléaire mais
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi notre pays n'a pas encore
réussi à obtenir la décorrélation du
prix de l'électricité du gaz comme on
réussi à le faire l'Espagne et le
Portugal merci merci
Sylviane Anne-Catherine Loisier et
ensuite Patrick Chauvet merci Madame la
présente merci messieurs pour toutes les
informations que vous nous avez confié
donc peut-être deux trois petites
questions complémentaires tout à l'heure
monsieur véranc vous avez évoqué donc la
disponibilité aujourd'hui qui au-delà de
ce qu'on pouvait espérer
donc à 41,3 gigawatts Monsieur Raymond
c'est bien donc si les trois réocteurs
que vous avez évoqués sont opérationnel
d'ici Noël plus un début janvier ou en
seront nous en termes de capacité de
disponible vous avez beaucoup aussi
évoqué la problématique compétence
expérience
comment est-ce que vous appréhendez je
dirais notre niveau de dépendance aux
compétences étrangères aujourd'hui
puisqu'on entendait il y a quelques
jours que c'était des ingénieurs
américains qui étaient mobilisés sur un
certain nombre de noces donc comment
vous appréhendez cette dépendance en
fait aux compétences étrangères et puis
dans la même ligne
pensez-vous aujourd'hui que le le
maillon des sous-traitants et des
industriels plus de l'amour soit solide
et en capacité de répondre à ces enjeux
et sinon que que
préconisez-vous en ce sens merci merci
Anne-Catherine et pour terminer Patrick
Chauvet merci madame la Présidente
merci à nos intervenants je croyais
saluer nos rapporteurs
si on a souffert d'un manque de
stratégie moi je suis heureux qu'on est
maintenant une perspective une
prospective
j'ai été heureux aussi d'entendre qu'on
rappelait qu'on avait une production
grâce à l'hydroélectricité et que c'est
pas rien en France je voudrais juste
revenir mais ça a été abordé je j'ai été
surpris que vous vous inquiétez pas les
nouvelles techniques les nouvelles
technologies puisqu'on est sur des temps
longs et notamment de n'a pas avoir
évoqué le projet ITER cela a été dit aux
États-Unis et le progresse sur ce projet
de fusion alors il y a-t-il des raisons
pour lesquelles vous ne l'avez pas
évoqué soit vous n'y croyez pas
soit vous y croyez et si vous y croyez
et quand vous regardez même si on est
sur des temps longs on sera très proche
des échéances que que vous évoquez et si
ça marche ça change la donne ça change
la donne du programme donc merci à vous
pour les éléments pour apporter
bien merci beaucoup à tous pour la
précision et la concision de vos
questions j'en vois pas d'autres il y a
pas d'autres demandes de prise de parole
très bien je vais commencer par donner
la parole à Monsieur véranc et puis on
fera le voilà le mouvement
inverse d'accord voilà
bien je vais
finalement pas tant de questions qui
m'était qui mettaient destiné plutôt
celle de la fin sur la disponibilité du
nucléaire
bon moi je
vous rappelle que la façon dont nous on
fait des prévisions elles ne sont pas
réacteurs par réacteur ça c'est c'est le
travail de l'exploitant et je pense au
lucrément il répondra mieux que moi nous
ce qui compte c'est la disponibilité
globale du parc en intégrant un certain
nombre de facteurs c'est que sur
nucléaire comme sur n'importe quel
installation industrielle il y a un
certain nombre d'aléas donc nous on
intègre une vision probabiliste des
aléas et c'est avec ces visions
probabilistes qu'on est arrivés à notre
trajectoire quand on regarde au cours
des trois derniers mois
les étoiles ont été assez largement
tenues il y a un petit décroché au cours
du mois de au cours du mois de novembre
mais on est revenu dessus et
effectivement je pense qu'on sera entre
entre 41 à 42 et un peu plus début du
mois de janvier ça reste une situation
qui est qui
je préférerais avoir 50 Go 55 gigawatts
en janvier comme on a comme ça pouvait
être le cas il y a quelques années mais
quand on parlait des incertitudes tout à
l'heure il y a quand même qu'on se rend
compte que le parking clair qui
produitait plus de 400 TW va en produire
280 cette année environ et que le fait
qu'on arrive à s'adapter à cette
situation étant a été une prouesse donc
si on est autour de 45 gigawatts pour le
mois de janvier effectivement la
situation sera sera meilleur que celle
qu'on pouvait qu'on pouvait anticiper au
cours en septembre après au cours des
prochaines années manuel vous avez
demandé si on allait avoir devoir
prévoir du délestage non je crois pas
j'espère pas en tout cas et alors
comment fait-on pour boucler alors déjà
la France était un pays exportateur et
je pense qu'elle redeviendra un pays
exportateur d'électricité
on exportait beaucoup d'électricité
puisque
durant la période entre 2000 et 2010 la
France a pu exporter 80 watts et encore
quelques années on pouvait être sur
l'ordre de 50 60 donc cette année
exceptionnellement la France va être
importatrice
mais la trajectoire et les prévisions
conduisent à se dire qu'on ne sera pas
un portateur au cours de l'année 2023 et
qu'ensuite on retrouvera un sol
d'exportateur ensuite la façon de
boucler notre notre trajectoire
c'est d'augmenter la production
d'électricité notamment la production
des carbonées pour cela il y a plusieurs
leviers
le premier levier c'est de garder notre
parc nucléaire existant et de ne pas
fermer de réacteurs le deuxième c'est
fait en sorte que le parc nucléaire
existant produise et retrouve une des
standards de production qui sont proches
de ce qu'il faisait auparavant je suis
pas certain je pense qu'il faut être
réaliste ce sera je pense pas qu'on
reviendra au sud 400 terawh rapidement
mais si on peut être au dessus de 350
térawats c'est déjà une situation qui
qui est beaucoup plus confortable que
celle de cette année et puis le reste ça
sera en développement des énergies
renouvelables
voilà donc c'est pour ça que on ne l'a
dit très clairement dans notre rapport
futur énergétique 2050 à l'horizon 2030
le scénario qui permet
qui est le plus le plus efficace d'un
point de vue économique qui permet qu'il
est plus efficace du point de vue des
émissions de CO2
et qui est le meilleur du point de vue
de la sécurité d'approvisionnement c'est
celui où on combine le maintien du parc
existant et le développement des
énergies renouvelables avec des efforts
d'efficacité énergétique voire de
sobriété
merci Monsieur vérante monsieur Durot
es
j'ai commencé par ça
alors je rappelle juste que donc nous on
propose de la fourniture d'uranium après
eDF va décider sa propre politique de
choix et d'achat et c'est de comment
dire de bonnes politiques que de
diversifier
ses sources d'approvisionnement par
rapport à ceux qui offrent de l'uranium
donc sa complémente aussi les risques
géopolitiques au niveau de au niveau de
Ranno donc je rappelle que nous avons
une politique volontaire de
diversification des mines au niveau
mondial donc nous avons des mines au
Niger nous avons des mines au Canada
nous avons des mines Kazakhstan nous
sommes en train de mettre en oeuvre des
pilotes en Mongolie et comme vous avez
pu le voir récemment nous avons aussi
des projets miniers en Ouzbékistan donc
ça couvre à la fois une variété et un
spectre de pays relativement large
avec avec des aspects aussi
technologiques qui sont divers donc les
techniques employées et mise en oeuvre
sont distinctes voilà je pense pour la
partie approvisionnement après sur le
tiend industriel lui-même tel que je
l'ai dit il est en France et l'enjeu est
très directement le développement
il y a une question où j'en prends un
peu aussi sur sur le développement en
matière de métier
on va pas dire que tout se fait en
un instant immédiat il y a une volonté
très claire et très forte d'avancer ça
se fait au niveau de la filière au
niveau du gifen
d'ailleurs il y a bien une université
mise en place par la filière et et ça
fédère l'ensemble des actions que les
grands on va dire donneur d'ordre mais
aussi tout le tissu industriel
à identifier et estime avoir besoin
comme ça a été dit à juste titre il y a
à la fois tout l'aspect colle bleu dont
on a besoin et donc de retrouver les
niveaux d'exigence donc j'avais donné
l'exemple des soudeurs il y en a
évidemment bien d'autres c'est faire
aussi évoluer ces métiers on les
adaptant peut-être aux connaissances
telles qu'on les a en terme de mise en
oeuvre et de pratique dans le 21e siècle
je vais juste donner un exemple la
radioprotection n'est peut-être plus à
faire de la même manière qu'elle se
faisait la fin du siècle dernier il y a
beaucoup de choses qui peuvent être
adaptés à évoluer et enfin du côté du
métier ingénieur alors souvent on cite
les effectifs de sortie d'école
d'ingénieurs
moi je tiens à rappeler je le dis aussi
régulièrement à mes propres équipes on
forme de très bons ingénieurs même s'ils
n'ont pas forcément le diplôme
d'ingénieur dans nos universités un
Master 2 peut avoir un niveau de
compétence largement utilisable et
d'ailleurs nous y avons amplement
recours et c'est extrêmement je pense
important dans la durée
et le dernier point donc vous avez bien
compris qu'on avance cette concert
il y a eu une question tout à l'heure
sur sur le plan Excel au niveau de Ranno
nous avons pendant qu'ils bambouste et
en tant que sponsor de ce plan j'ai de
manière extrêmement régulière avec
Monsieur Transer qui est donc le
responsable du plan Excel chez EDF et ça
fait bien partie aussi des
problématiques qu'on a par la suite et
on a commencé à échanger sur le sujet
parce que tous les deux avons décidé de
clore le plan pour passer à la phase
ultérieure de déploiement et dans dans
les phases ultérieures de déploiement
qui comprennent aussi d'ailleurs la
maîtrise de des projets c'est aussi
s'assurer que on ne sera pas en guerre
de talent entre guillemets les uns les
autres parce que c'est complètement
inutile mais que au contraire en
fonction de nos propres compétences il y
a des choses qu'on sait faire chez Orano
qui sont un peu moins bien connus chez
EDF je parle pas juste du cycle je parle
vraiment des typologies de métier et
inversement comment faire et comment
sont concertés de manière intelligente
pour avancer pour avancer sur le sujet
il y a une question très directe qui a
été posée sur la saturation des piscines
de la Hague donc je rappellerai que de
manière concertée avec EDF nous
cherchons à résoudre ce problème sous
l'oeil je dirais extrêmement vigilant de
l'autorité sur tnucléaire qui est
particulièrement exigeante à juste titre
sur le sujet parce que ça peut être une
menace d'engorgement pour la filière et
donc nous travaillons de concert et très
directement la première des choses que
nous faisons c'est regarder comment
densifier les piscines de la Hague pour
s'assurer on a décidé tout à l'heure
l'horizon 2030 potentiellement ça peut
être un petit peu plus tard en termes de
points d'interrogation donc on a le
temps de voir venir on a d'autant plus
le temps de voir venir qu'on a décidé de
ne pas ignorer le sujet et de s'y
attaquer de manière très directe
enfin j'avais donc une question
extrêmement spécifique sur
dans ma connaissance des mines qui ne
mettaient pas posée
sur ce qu'on appelle je crois le site le
site des bois noir bien alors sur le
site des bois noir je ne peux pas avoir
tous les éléments de réponse tel que
celle que là parce que je ne connaissais
pas le sujet de la lame d'eau qui était
passée au dessus moi de ce que je
connaissais sachant que l'acquisition
avait été posée mon directeur général
par mois de manière directe
le la station de traitement donc qui a
été mise en place
une efficacité qui était relevée à plus
de 98% donc qui portait donc
satisfaction et il y avait un certain
nombre d'actions d'améliorations du
procédé qui avait été entreprises
par par filtration sur un certain sur
des éolithes désolé pour le terme emploi
un peu technique employé au niveau des
grands bassins et donc ça ça a été mis
en oeuvre en septembre 2022
je comprends que le passage de
débordement est postérieur je ne sais
pas vous répondre très directement donc
ça c'est un point sur lequel on
reviendra vers vous de manière de
manière plus directe
je pense que sur les questions qui
m'était posées je à peu près un pendu à
tout merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je vais donner la parole à
Monsieur je fais que dans quel sens
habitent Monsieur Jacques peut-être on
finira comme ça merci Madame ma
présidente alors bon je je prends si
elle est rapide en sur ce que ce que
j'ai relevé peut-être un mot à la
croisée de en complément de ce que
disait
Guillaume sur sur les questions
d'approvisionnement uranium c'est pas
pour me mettre à sa place c'est juste
pour reprendre cette question de nos
dépendances vis-à-vis de l'étranger et
remettre un ou deux ordres de grandeur
sur sur les consommations et sur notre
dépendance en uranium
d'abord première remarque très simple
c'est hélas des dépendances vis-à-vis de
l'étranger on en aura toujours je veux
dire c'est complètement illusoire de
penser qu'on sera qu'on sera en
situation autarcique le tout c'est de
les avoir j'allais dire cartographier
ces dépendances et d'essayer de les
paliers parce que parce qu'on voit bien
qu'on en aura sur des critique on en
aura sur l'uranium on pourra en avoir
sur tel ou tel autre type de choses
il y a un problème de la globalisation à
gérer qui a fait qu'on n'avait pas de
masque et que est-ce que c'était
critique ou pas enfin bon voilà sur
l'approvisionnement uranium qui peut
être une question le dernier livre rouge
de l'énergie dit
au parc actuel
finalement et avec une de par le monde à
peu près 135 années et si on commence à
aller vers un très fort accroissement du
parc actuel on a 90 ou 100 ans devant
nous bon donc
mettons une centaine d'années pour pour
faire vite avec des des chroniques qui
sont quand même très ambitieuses de
construction ce qui ce qui fixe
finalement l'horizon de temps par
rapport au cycle et par rapport au
moment où on aurait besoin de réacteurs
d'une autre nature typiquement neutrons
rapide qui permettrait une meilleure
consommation de la matière et qui
permettrait de ne plus dépendre dans
l'approvisionnement d'uranium naturel
donc une centaine d'années je voulais
juste préciser ces constantes de temps
alors ça n'était pas de s'en occuper dès
maintenant mais mais je pense que
c'était c'était important
sur je sais pas qui qui veut qui veut se
prendre la question sur les déchets mais
je veux je veux bien la prendre en
présentant mes excuses par avance à mes
lointains successeur d'abord pour dire
une chose moi j'ai toujours vous avez
complètement raison quand vous dites
qu'il faut faire de la pédagogie sur les
déchets moi j'ai toujours été frappé de
de ce point de cette abscède fixation
sur les déchets alors que de mon point
de vue c'est quand même une des choses
qui qui est extrêmement bien gérée avec
extrêmement de rigueur qui est tout ça
est en fait vraiment de manière que je
salue comme je m'en occupe plus que ça
subit beaucoup s'améliorer depuis que je
suis parti je salue Laura pour dire que
c'est vraiment fait avec beaucoup
d'exemplarités beaucoup de beaucoup de
rigueur et que je pense que dans la
proportionnalité du risque et donc on
est capable d'expliquer aux citoyens
effectivement on peut leur montrer que
les déchets quand même il faut il faut
relativiser un certain nombre de choses
on les cartographies on essaye de
trouver des solutions on n'avance pas à
pas de ce point de vue là par rapport à
la question sur sur les parcs et sur six
géo c'est-à-dire là aussi il faut être
un peu il faut être un peu
relatif c'est à dire que si géo a des
flexibilités au sens où il y a des
inventaires il y a un inventaire de
référence il y a des inventaires de
réserves qui permettent de traiter les
marges alors après les marges qui se
traitent aussi par des questions de
thermique des questions d'inventer etc
ce que je veux dire c'est par rapport à
ça c'est que de toute façon il faut pas
voir ça comme un sujet figé comme je le
disais il y aura de la production de
déchets il y en a eu il y en aura et
donc l'idée que on a tout réglé les
déchets une fois pour toutes et qui a
pas la gestion des déchets dans la durée
est une idée est une idée fausse en
revanche le fait d'avoir prouvé une
faisabilité ou de l'avoir fait évaluer
d'un point de vue sureté d'avoir obtenu
le cadre réglementaire qui permet et qui
permet de progresser je crois nous met
sur la voie de la question de traitement
des déchets donc je serai pas forcément
inquiet sur ce point-là et puis alors il
m'en restait une il m'en restait deux je
pense une sur la fusion je vous promets
et j'y viens juste sur les jeunes quand
même et sur nos formations je crois que
là-dessus faut se dire les choses on est
moi si je le prends par exemple sous la
question chercheur typiquement chercheur
la constante de temps c'est 5 ans c'est
la thèse le postdoc c'est 3 + 2 donc ne
rêvons pas et alors ça sera nous aurons
à à reconstituer ou à constituer un
certain nombre quelque chose qui fait
que ça va pas être évident d'avoir des
milliers dans quel que soit le
compartiment du jeu en revanche le fait
que nous ayons une perspective le fait
qu'il y ait de l'innovation c'est pour
ça aussi que les SMR sont importants le
fait qu'il y ait toutes ces choses là
doivent nous permettre de montrer aux
jeunes qui a des grands projets il y a
de l'avenir il y a de l'avenir non
seulement dans la reproduction de ce
qu'on faisait autrefois en mieux mais
aussi dans des choses différentes et ça
je crois que c'est important alors la
fusion je vous promets donc pour bien
clarifier les choses ce dont il a été
tenant de vous avez eu des annonces de
la part du du type de l'énergie mardi
c'est pardon je vais être obligé de
faire un tout petit peu technique très
rapidement la fusion par confinement
inertiel donc ce sont des lasers ce
n'est pasitaire ce n'est pas la voix
Uther ça n'a rien à voir avec la voix
terre donc ce sont et qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est le NIF donc c'est Laurent de
laboratoire qui est en fait un peu
l'équivalent du laser mégajul en France
à la direction des applications
militaires c'est-à-dire c'est une
installation qui vise à faire des
expériences de simulation pour des gens
qui ne peuvent plus faire d'essai pour
les armes nucléaires voilà c'est c'est
ça le point et donc ils ont obtenu un
stade dit de break even c'est à dire que
la quantité d'énergie envoyée sur une
microbille de tritium de terium a été
supérieur à celle qui a envoyé ça ne
veut pas dire que ces producteurs
d'énergie parce que si vous intégrez
toute l'énergie tout au long de la
chaîne ça n'est pas producteur d'énergie
à ce stade là ce n'est que l'énergie
compte tenu des rendements ce n'est que
l'énergie qui arrive sur la sphère qui
est supérieur etc donc ça mais ceci dit
c'est une magnifique réalisation et je
pense que nous en aurons probablement
des des échos côté de la direction des
applications militaires puisque le
travail autour du laser mégajul est
aussi excellent et devrait produire le
même genre d'effet j'en viens à la voix
par contre dite par confinement
magnétique pardon d'être long là-dessus
mais donc là cette fois-ci nous sommes
bien d'accord c'est on confine non plus
on fait plus des micro-sibles avec des
lasers etc on est sur des process qui
ont plus de vocation à devenir
industrielle plus rapidement confinement
par des aimants donc on rapproche les
particules tout ça dans un tokamak ce
qu'on appelle un tokamak progénither
progénither et alors la question si je
vais droit au but c'est quand le projet
ITER produit-il ou quand le successeur
du projet ITER parce que ça ne sera
pasitaire produira-t-il de l'énergie de
fusion bien écoutez je je
vais prendre ma boule de cristal mais
enfin de toute façon soyons sérieux le
projet qu'on connaît en plus à centre de
difficultés aujourd'hui diverses et
variés mais qui sont normales comme dans
tous les projets psychologique deuxième
moitié de ce siècle au mieux et et moi
je sais que Bernard Bigot avec une
pensée émue pour lui était plus avec le
caractère visionnaire qu'il avait à long
que je ne le suis tout le monde sait que
je suis un peu toujours pessimiste mais
fin de ce siècle
pas avant fin de ce siècle
merci madame la Présidente je vais
essayer de naître rapide et manuellement
me centrer sur les questions qui sont en
rapport avec avec la sûreté tout d'abord
pour répondre au sénateur salmon je
dirais que en ce qui concerne la prise
en compte du retour d'expérience de le
père de tyshan concernant les problèmes
de combustible et de d'hydraulique dans
dans la cuve donc c'est clair que nous
avons demandé à EDF de prendre en compte
ce retour d'expérience dès la conception
de le père de dans toutes les
conclusions qui ont été tirées de
l'analyse aussi ce qui est passé à Tyson
notamment sur l'hydraulique seront
intégrés sur le père de
en ce qui concerne la question sur la
saturation des piscines de la Hague donc
ça ça a été déjà évoqué le point
essentiel et j'y reviens parce que c'est
vraiment un mot clé c'est la question de
l'anticipation la saturation des
piscines d'entreposage de la Hague était
identifié depuis plus de 10 ans puis de
10 ans la nécessité d'avoir un projet
complémentaire développé par EDF avec
une piscine centralisée avait été
prescrit par voie réglementaire les
échéances n'ont pas été respectées et
aujourd'hui le projet connaît des
difficultés des vicissitudes notamment
nos concertations il ne sera pas
disponible avant l'horizon 2034 alors
que les piscines seront saturées avant
2030 parce que il y a certains nombre de
fragilités d'aléas sur l'usine notamment
Melox qui pourrait conduire à ce que la
fasse saturation soit en 2029 donc il va
falloir gérer la période de 2029 2034 où
les piscines seront centrales des
piscines actuelles seraient saturées
s'il n'y avait pas parade mise en oeuvre
et donc aujourd'hui nous travaillons sur
les demandes qui ont été formulées par
Orano notamment pour pouvoir densifier
les piscines actuelles de telle manière
à offrir une parade et de ne pas avoir
de saturation des piscines ça illustre
parfaitement le sujet de l'anticipation
et j'y reviens avec la question du
sénateur menthoget sur finalement
j'évoquais précédemment le risque de
voir considérer la poursuite
d'exploitation des réacteurs actuels
comme une variable d'ajustement là
encore par défaut d'anticipation c'est à
dire si on ne programme pas les
opérations de toute nature qui sont
nécessaires pour pouvoir passer la
période d'abord 2022 2035 ou la
l'augmentation des besoins en énergie
électrique va de toute façon se
présenter sans qu'il y ait de projets
nucléaires nouveau mais ensuite il y
aura tout ce qui se passera après 2035
et notamment l'effet falaise dont on a
parlé c'est-à-dire les réacteurs actuels
s'arrêteront bien un jour qu'on les
arrête à 50 en passant ou 70 ans il
s'arrêteront et ils ont été construits à
75% pendant une période de 10 ans donc
pendant 10 ans on va les arrêter c'est
vraiment une falaise donc il va falloir
anticiper cet effet falaise et ça c'est
maintenant qu'il faut y réfléchir
alors on est sûr de rien mais je veux
dire qu'aujourd'hui on a rien démontré
je ne dis pas que c'est pas possible de
poursuivre l'exploitation des réacteurs
actuels au-delà de 50 au-delà de 60 pour
l'instant c'est limité à autoriser que
jusqu'à 50 c'est la demande qui nous a
été faite et nous l'avons instruite mais
si on veut se projeter sur à 60 à 70 ans
voire plus il faut centrer maintenant
parce que la hauteur de la marche elle
est considérable et donc il faudra
programmer des projets de toute nature
il s'agit pas de parler uniquement de
nucléaire il y a des renouvelables il y
a de l'efficacité énergétique il y a
d'autres projets mais il faut avoir une
vision une vision pour planifier cet
indispensable c'est dans les 5 ans qui
viennent qu'il faut traiter ce sujet
donc l'anticipation et les valable pour
le cycle du combustible comme elle est
bien hivernale sur la production
électrique électronucléaire
troisième sujet que je voulais aborder
c'est le question de la du sénateur
Michou sur la question de finalement les
réacteurs qui sont affectés aujourd'hui
de corrosion sous contrainte et
finalement la remise en service
directeurs les plus affectés d'ici et ça
que 16 6 14 réacteurs dans un pari donc
moi je tiens à souligner que je rappelle
la corrosion sous contrainte c'est un
sujet sérieux en termes de sûreté mais
qui a été traité très sérieusement par
EDF
les décisions qui ont été prises pendant
le premier semestre 2022 était
indispensable elles ont été Lourdes en
conséquence de disponibilité du parc
mais c'était indispensables il y avait
aucun moyen de savoir où était ses
fissurations quel était leur taille et
la manière de les traiter il y avait
aucun Rex international qui permettait
de le faire s'il les décisions qui ont
été prises par EDF ne l'avait pas été
nous aurions été en aveugle et dans le
brouillard et incapable de prendre les
décisions qui ont été prises sur propos
d'EDF des l'été et ici maintenant à
partir de l'automne donc maintenant nous
disposons d'une analyse suffisamment
étayée que nous avons accepté sur la
priorisation à mettre en oeuvre la
priorité c'est 16 réacteurs c'est pas 56
c'est 16 réacteurs et un certain nombre
d'entre eux ont déjà été mis à l'arrêt
et réparer donc l'ampleur du problème
CSC n'est pas ne peut pas expliquer la
totalité de la disponibilité c'est une
part il y a 16 réacteurs et c'est 16
réacteurs qui sont les quatre réacteurs
N4 et les 12 réacteurs d'un palier qui
s'appelle P prime 4 du 13100 doivent
être
réparés c'est engagement pris par EDF à
l'occasion des arrêts programmés donc on
met pas à l'arrêt les réacteurs on
attend la rétrograder pour les réparer
d'ici 2023 c'est ça la stratégie qui a
été proposée par EDF au vu du retour
d'expérience et que nous avons validé
et la dernière question que je voulais
évoquer je crois c'est celle du CET
artichaut concernant les déchets donc je
confirme ce qui a été dit sur on évitera
jamais les déchets je confirme également
que nous avons absolument pas
je dirais de
n'a pas à souffrir de comparaison avec
le reste du monde en termes de gestion
des déchets nous envoie en France et
c'est d'ailleurs systématiquement
remarqué lorsque nous rapportons devant
la i.e.a de la manière dont nous
traitons les déchets on a plutôt des
louanges nous avons un plan national de
gestion des matières et des déchets
radioactifs d'ailleurs le cinquième plan
vient enfin d'être publié et nous avons
pour ce qui est concerne le projet Cigéo
de stockage en coupe géologique de
profonde on est parmi les pays du monde
les plus avancés même si c'est un sujet
complexe pour retrouver une solution
durable à ce problème et donc vraiment
il n'a pas de honte à avoir c'est un
sujet qui est très bien traité
c'est la valve c'est bien la valve du
cycle après Laval du cycle
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président et le mot de la fin enfin les
mots de la fin
directeur général merci madame la
Présidente je vais essayer de répondre à
vos questions en tout cas pour celles
qui n'ont pas déjà trouvé leur réponse
dans les réponses de mes collègues
donc le risque les EP2 ne soient pas la
temps et que
le parc soit la variable d'ajustement
je vais formuler avec les mots de
l'exploitant ce que le président
d'origine vient de dire nous devons
aborder la prolongation de la durée de
vie du parc de façon industrielle et
avec une option avec une évidemment une
vision sur la sûreté du parc nous
apprenons énormément en ce moment en
travaillant sur la corrosion sous
contrainte qui était un phénomène
inattendu donc nous apprenons énormément
sur sur l'état de des tuyauteries sur
l'état des soudures etc etc donc
tout cela va nous conduire
euh à tirer les leçons de cette phase là
et et aborder évidemment les vitres les
visites des Sénats suivantes avec ces
leçons apprises avec une un objectif qui
est évidemment de nous convaincre
nous-mêmes pour commencer de la
possibilité de pérenniser au-delà de 50
ans l'exploitation des réacteurs
existants parce que c'est l'intérêt du
pays et c'est l'intérêt de la capacité
de produire que d'y arriver mais il faut
que nous nous en convainquions
nous-mêmes bien sûr et ensuite il faut
qu'on en convaincre l'autorité sûreté
évidemment puisque l'Autorité de sûreté
et aura son jugement totalement
indépendant et totalement instruitement
de la même façon et dans ces conditions
je ne vois pas à ce stade de raison que
nous puissions pas envisager d'aller au
delà des 50 ans comme les américains
l'ont fait sur des designs qui sont
équivalents en autre à condition qu'on
prenne ça de façon systémique comme
comme Bernard de le dire néanmoins
il est absolument indispensable d'aller
le plus vite possible sur la
construction d'un parc neuf ne serait-ce
que parce que la demande électrique
augmente et parce que s'il y a une
expérience collective que nous pouvons
tirer de cet hiver c'est que quand le
parc nucléaire n'est pas en état de
produire au maximum de ses capacités
l'instabilité de notre propre parc de
production au total
n'est pas la stabilité du parc de
production au total n'est pas suffisante
pour nous assurer l'autosuffisance donc
aujourd'hui nous passons grâce à la
flexibilité qui nous est permise par
l'importation
sur le montage financier est-ce que le
législateur a une place
je vais en profiter pour répondre à la
question de Monsieur gay sur le même
sujet et plusieurs d'entre vous à la fin
il y a que deux personnes qui peuvent
payer
le client ou l'usager selon le terme
qu'on emploie qui est une personne et le
deuxième c'est le contribuable je sais
les deux seules personnes qui peuvent
payer à la fin
pas tout à fait parce que le client il
veut des mégawatts voilà ou des water
voilà donc le client lui il souhaite
avoir un service donc il paye pour un
service le contribuable il vous délègue
si je puis me permettre la faculté de
décider à sa place
l'usage des montants qui sont collectés
sur le contribuable voilà donc il n'y a
que ces deux qui peuvent qui peuvent
payer à la fin EDF dans ce cas
EDF vend un service auprès de ses
clients et le souhait de l'entreprise
c'est de pouvoir voir vendre un service
qui correspond au coût quel langage sur
la durée et vendre un service sur la
durée correspondant au couple et langage
je veux dire qu'on intègre les coûts
complets du cycle et qu'on intègre le
coût de renouvellement est-ce que dans
l'état actuel de la régulation et des
règles de marché EDF peut faire ça la
réponse est non donc c'est bien l'un des
sujets sur lesquels nous devons
travailler
voilà donc je le dis donc c'est bien des
sujets sur lesquels nous devons
travailler bon j'ai commencé à y
travailler mais je suis là que depuis
trois semaines donc il me faut encore un
tout petit peu de travail avec les
autorités gouvernementales et
communautaires pour arriver vers des
règles de marché et des règles
applicables à EDF qui nous permettent
d'aller dans cette direction
ça peut ne pas suffire ça peut ne pas
suffire il y a d'autres types de
technologie énergétiques et aujourd'hui
ne trouve pas leur financement complet
avec simplement la faculté de vendre un
service aux clients donc les
renouvelables pour commencer ce sont
développés grâce à des dispositifs de
financement qui ont un soutien public
même les centrales à gaz d'une certaine
manière lorsqu'elle dispose de marché de
capacité ont un soutien public aussi
donc le fait d'avoir une économie de ce
que nous vendons au client qui soit la
plus proche possible du coup complet
peut ne pas suffire dans le dispositif
de financement auquel cas naturellement
il faudra toujours avec l'accord et le
soutien du gouvernement et dans un cadre
communautaire définir un dispositif qui
permet de compléter cela soit par des
garanties soit par un dispositif de
financement public comme ça existe dans
d'autres pays aujourd'hui et nous avons
récemment d'ailleurs conclu un accord
sur le projet sizewell dans lequel nous
avons un dispositif de financement
accompagné par les autorités
britanniques donc c'est l'ensemble de ce
dispositif qui nous faut élaborer nous
avons encore un peu de temps pour le
faire puisque il faut l'avoir pour la
décision finale d'investissement et nous
sommes encore à plus d'une année de la
décision finale d'investissement quelle
réforme de marché pour accompagner tout
cela principal défaut du marché le
marché d'aujourd'hui il a des qualités
donc il faut pas le jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain il permet l'équilibre de
court terme s'il n'y avait pas de marché
d'aujourd'hui nous serions aujourd'hui
en situation très difficile pour
importer la quantité d'électricité qui
nous perdent permet de faire l'équilibre
au jour le jour donc il faut pas jeter
les qualités du marché d'aujourd'hui qui
ont permis cette équipe de court terme
le marché a des défauts qui sont mis en
lumière par la situation de crise
énergétique à l'échelle européenne et
les défauts sont ceux que vous avez
cités donc le couplage gaz électricité
effectivement induit une hyper
volatilité des prix de l'électricité
comparé à la proportion d'électricité
générée par le gaz donc c'est un des
défauts qu'il nous faut traiter et le
deuxième défaut qui nous faut traiter
c'est que comme le marché est orienté
court terme il ne donne pas de signal
d'investissement et il ne permet pas
d'établir
un équilibre long terme entre des
producteurs et des clients finaux donc
c'est le deuxième sujet sur lequel il
nous faut travailler nous y travaillons
c'est bien sûr
aux autorités gouvernementales de
définir les règles de marché ensemble à
l'échelle communautaire je sais que le
gouvernement français il travaille très
activement avec les autorités
communautaires pour moi il y a un
élément clé qui doit apparaître
davantage dans les règles de marché qui
est la faculté de conclure des contrats
de long terme
à la place d'une régulation qui oblige
l'exploitant nucléaire aujourd'hui à
vendre la production de son parc à un
prix fixé de façon
administrative donc c'est vraiment sur
cet axe là que je pense nous devons
forger les futurs règles de marché
je ne reviens pas sur six géo parce que
je pense que François Jaqui a répondu
assez largement sur le risque que je
géopolitique je pense que
Guillaume Durot a répondu assez
largement je peux juste ajouter un mot
c'est que pour EDF nous avons une
stratégie d'approvisionnement qui est
évidemment
et repose très largement sur une
collaboration étroite avec Orano mais
qui ne se limite pas à la collaboration
étroite avec Orano nous a une stratégie
de contrat de long terme et de source
diversifiées d'approvisionnement le but
étant effectivement de diversifier nos
risques comme n'importe quel industriel
le ferait face à des
approvisionnements critiques
je crois que pour Monsieur Tissot
Guillaume du Roi avait pour l'essentiel
répondu
alors Monsieur Michaud sur combien à
l'arrêt début 2023 donc nous avons
aujourd'hui 15 réacteurs qui sont en
arrêt pour travaux 8 qui sont donc 8 qui
sont en arrêt programmées donc c'est les
visites des Sénats et les visites
périodiques 6 sont en visite décennale
donc c'est les arrêts les plus longs
clairement
six réacteurs sont encore en travaux
dans le cadre de la corrosion sous
contrainte et donc les travaux vont se
poursuivre dans les dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent avec la plus
grande vitesse possible évidemment et
nous avons un réacteur qui fait encore
l'objet de contrôle dans le cadre de la
corrosion sous contrainte qui est celui
de Flamanville 1
donc après on va rentrer dans le mois de
janvier évidemment la vie du parc va
continuer c'est à dire que il y a un
certain nombre de réacteurs qui vont
être rattrapés par les besoins de
rechargement de combustible de visites
périodiques de visite décennale etc donc
je suis pas en train de vous dire qu'on
va juste raccorder tous les réacteurs au
fur et à mesure l'objectif c'est que en
janvier et le plus tôt possible en mois
de juin au mois de janvier nous
atteignons les 45 g de disponible
ensuite
monsieur méryou m'avait demandé
quel était le cap et quelles étaient
est-ce qu'il y avait des contradictions
entre l'arrêt de certains réacteurs et
là et les opera2 donc je pense que j'ai
déjà répondu
sur la sobriété
le prix de l'électricité étant un
élément déterminant du potentiellement
de la sobriété alors ce que nous
observons aujourd'hui c'est que dans les
fêtes sobriété chez les clients les
réactions sont pas les mêmes en fonction
des catégories de clients les clients
particuliers ont réellement je crois
suivi ce qui est remarquable l'appel à
la sobriété que toute la filière le
gouvernement tout le monde a lancé il
contribue massivement au fait que nous
soyons en situation d'équilibre
aujourd'hui
naturellement s'agissant des entreprises
je suis extrêmement sensible et je
l'avais déjà dit leur demande audition
au fait que les prix constituent un
impact massif pour pour certaines
d'entre elles le gouvernement a pris des
dispositions que nous allons
naturellement exécuter le plus vite
possible dans les semaines qui viennent
pour permettre des amortisseurs sur sur
les prix
au-delà de ça je pense que
il va falloir tenir cette logique de
sobriété pendant l'hiver au total et je
pense qu'il y a simplement les mesures
que nous sommes en train de discuter sur
les règles de marché je l'espère pour me
permettre de calmer la volatilité dans
laquelle se trouve le marché de
l'électricité aujourd'hui pour ce qui
concerne EDF encore une fois si nous
étions capables de si nous étions
autorisés à formuler des contrats de
long terme avec la plupart de nos
clients dans des conditions qui sont
compatibles avec notre coût complet de
renouvellement on serait très en dessous
des prix de marché d'aujourd'hui et nous
serions très heureux de le faire mais
pour cela il faut que les règles de
marché nous autorisent à le faire
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
enfin Monsieur
monsieur salmon qui n'est plus là je
crois qui va m'écouter donc je reprends
à mon compte la réponse du président
dorosuc sur
sur les conclusions tirées de Tashan
peut-être en ajoutant d'un point que
pour ce qui me concerne pas la cuve mais
le la partie combustible et assemblage
des flamants ville 3 on a tiré des
conséquences et sur EPR 2 ça sera
directement sur le circuit hydraulique
sur Laval et sur la saturation des
piscines de la Hague je reprends mon
compte ce qui était dit par Guillaume
Durot nous travaillons main dans la main
avec l'autorité et avec Orano pour
trouver une solution j'ajoute que dès
mon premier soir j'étais avec les élus
de la Manche pour discuter de ce sujet
après avoir fait la visite de
Flamanville 3
madame gacquère
modalité de financement exact
je suis désolé femme donnait encore un
peu de temps mais je prends l'engagement
de revenir devant vous dès que on aura
un dispositif
qui soit complètement instruit et pour
pouvoir le partager avec vous
sur la gestion des déchets partage tout
ce qui était dit par mes collègues sur
le fait que c'est un des éléments clés
de l'ensemble du cycle et que d'ailleurs
l'économie de du futur du nucléaire doit
intégrer absolument l'aval du cycle dans
dans la façon dont nous déterminons
l'économie du futur du nucléaire sur les
démantèlements nous avons effectivement
neuf réacteurs en cours de démantèlement
je peux pas vous confirmer le chiffre de
400 millions par réacteur parce que je
l'ai pas par coeur encore à ce stade
simplement nous révisons régulièrement
dans le cadre de la politique de
provisionnement d'EDF pour le
démantèlement le coût du démantèlement
et comme nous commençons à démanteler
maintenant des premiers réacteurs à eau
pressurisé nous pouvons aussi
ré-op réaliser enfin tirer les leçons de
ses premiers démantèlement pour être sûr
que nous maîtrisons l'exercice et pour
que nous puissions l'amener au bon
niveau de maîtrise industrielle
monsieur gay m'avait demandé sur les
points très importants de l'attractivité
de la filière nucléaire j'espère que
j'ai déjà à peu près répondu sur qui va
payer monsieur gay sur l'attractivité
qui est un sujet absolument essentiel
et ça me permettrait de répondre à
d'autres questions au passage je suis
encore un peu récent dans le métier mais
de ce que j'ai pu voir en me déplaçant
beaucoup sur le terrain sur les premiers
jours je suis pas inquiet d'un problème
de qualité des compétences
je pense qu'on a on a des compétences de
qualité on a un problème de quantité et
le problème de quantité il est lié au
fait que la filière n'a pas construit
depuis longtemps en tout cas la PAF
construite de façon industrielle depuis
longtemps il est lié aussi que notre
pays c'est un petit peu
contracté sur les métiers techniques en
général
et que
et c'est à l'échelle du pays c'est pas
la chaîne d'une filière et puis il est
lié au fait que
temporairement aujourd'hui à cause de la
corrosion contrainte mais demain parce
que nous devons cumuler à la fois de la
construction neuve et des travaux qui en
fait sont aussi compliqués que de la
construction neuve sur la maintenance du
parc en réalité nos besoins numériques
nos besoins quantitatifs
vont vraiment croître massivement par
rapport à ce que nous avons connu même à
l'époque de la construction neuve du
premier parc donc ce dont nous parlons
c'est un effet démographique sur les
tous les métiers techniques et ils sont
tous égales importants
qui est lié en fait à la conjonction de
ces phénomènes pour probablement les
deux décennies qui nous attendent donc
il faut prendre ça comme comme un plan
industriel et c'est comme ça que nous le
prenons donc ça a commencé déjà depuis
plusieurs années maintenant il faut pas
passer la surmultiplier donc nous allons
continuer de prendre des initiatives
donc vous avez parlé des écoles des
métiers de deux métiers qui est un qui
est un concept auquel je crois
mais il y en a d'autres donc je pense
qu'il je sais bien je sais bien donc je
donc c'est un concept auquel je crois et
donc je suis en train de travailler
dessus mais pas seulement c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut vraiment qu'on regarde la
totalité des compétences et enfin voilà
on est un grand pays mais on n'est pas
non plus une population
infinie donc lorsque EDF continue de
faire des projet à l'étranger c'est
aussi pour avoir un bassin d'emploi qui
ne soit pas limité à la France parce que
le bassin d'emploi de la France n'est
pas suffisant en réalité pour engendrer
tous les besoins de la filière en tout
cas au moment de pic parce que là aussi
c'est pas c'est pas un plateau uniforme
sur 20 ans nous allons avoir des moments
dans lesquels on a besoin de tout le
monde et le phénomène de la corrosion
sous contrainte exactement celui-ci en
une période très limitée on a besoin de
toutes les compétences possibles et
c'est quand toutes ces compétences
possibles elles dépassent le chant
français voilà ce que je peux dire sur
les compétences
ensuite j'essaie d'accélérer madame la
Présidente
je crois que j'ai répondu à la réponse
sur les financement j'ai répondu à
toutes les questions de Monsieur gay
madame Noël m'avait demandé
comment remplir les besoins énergétiques
d'ici les nouveaux réacteurs
il y a d'autres investissements c'est
pas seulement
l'investissement dans le nucléaire je
pense que là
Thomas verin qui a bien a bien répondu
ce qui compte c'est moins de savoir
quelle est la quel est le modèle le plus
exact dans les proportions de chacune
des technologies à 20 ans parce que ça
on est sûr que si on cible sur un modèle
on va se tromper donc ce qui est très
bien je trouve dans l'approche qui a
pris le RTE c'est que l'erte nous donne
une finalement une carte une carte des
possibilités et on va on va apprendre à
naviguer dans cette carte des
possibilités en fonction de ce que nous
arrivons à réaliser dans toutes les
technologies et moi à ce stade j'ai une
seule certitude contenue des besoins des
carbonation qui passe essentiellement
par un besoin de davantage
d'électrification dans le pays
c'est qu'il nous faut faire tout ce que
nous pouvons le plus vite possible c'est
ma seule certitude à ce stade donc
évidemment toutes les technologies n'ont
pas le même temps et le temps du
nucléaire est le plus long d'où l'objet
de votre projet de loi qui permet de le
comprimer le plus possible en tout cas
pour la partie
autorisation et prêt chantier nous avons
le même défi pour ceux qui nous concerne
qui est de faire la même chose sur la
partie chantier mise en service etc et
la compression de ce temps et la
meilleure façon de répondre à la
question
madame Loisier ma petite question sur la
dépendance aux compétences étrangères
étrangère je pense que j'ai répondu
et sur la qualité de la sous-traitance
de la filière je pense que ma réponse
sur les compétences elle est vraie
autant de la filière qu'au sein de DF
j'ai déjà pu travailler avec beaucoup de
membres de la filière j'en viens à
moi-même d'une certaine manière donc le
problème de la filière n'est pas tant un
problème de qualité de compétence on a
une filière de qualité mais de quantité
quand vous avez un appareil industriel
qui est dimensionné pour livrer un
réacteur tous les 10 ans cet appareil
industriel et les compétences qui le
servent y compris dans la mise en oeuvre
doivent être démultipliés doivent être
dimensionnés à nouveau pour être capable
de répondre aux enjeux de la filière
pour l'avenir
et enfin je pense que pour Monsieur
Chauvet mon camarade
de droite assez largement répondu aux
nouvelles technologies qui sont qui
peuvent arriver j'y crois moi-même
beaucoup je viens d'une entreprise de
technologie donc j'y crois moi-même
beaucoup je pense qu'il faut surtout pas
que nous nous sous-estimons ce que la
technologie peut continuer d'apporter
donc François a parlé de stockage il a
parlé de nouveaux types de réacteurs il
a parlé de la gestion intelligente des
réseaux tous ces éléments sont
absolument clés et nous travaillons main
dans la main avec le CEA pour que
pour que le CEA face la partie
d'avant-garde et que nous soyons prêt à
suivre derrière en prenant le
déploiement voilà madame le Président
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
mais il me reste vous remercier tous les
cinq vraiment de cette audition qui
certes a été un petit peu longue mais
qui méritait vraiment le temps qu'on y a
consacré merci de vos expertises
individuelles et de votre expertise
collective voilà au service d'un des
éléments le plus important la
souveraineté quelle énergie donc merci
infiniment à tous je vous dis à tous à
bientôt on vous souhaitant de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année quand même entre
temps merci beaucoup merci infiniment